uh while we're framing up
uh welcome back to the true jordi
podcast for those
um who missed it uh big shout out before
we get started at jim sharp our sponsors
uh when we signed with them you know
they offered us lots of cool sports guys
and we are going to get
having some of them on but they also
said you know sean does cool sports you
know you do
you do you you be your true jolly
podcast what you've always been
and a big part of our little story our
journey
has been the man in front of me sean
atwood one of the most
loved guests we've ever had on the show
thank you so thanks for coming back i
wish it was under better
uh circumstances mate for those who
don't know we sort of talked about it on
social media lately
your best friend and one of the biggest
parts of your journey
wild man aka peter mahoney
has passed away very sadly one of my
regrets is that we didn't get him back
on and obviously
you know you em i'm busy doing this oh
we'll get them on we'll get them on
and it's just uh tragic uh when you sent
me that text
uh recently me heart went out to you
mate because uh i know how important
he's been to you so
um yeah you reached out to me just for
those who don't know and said you know
maybe
it'll be better to come on the podcast
and talk about it because
it's such a difficult thing to talk
about basically you guys
i have credited over and over again for
launching my youtube
and i'm hoping coming on here today is
going to help me relaunch because i've
not been able to pick up a camera since
wildman died
that was a few weeks ago now and people
saying all these people have done all
these tribute videos to him why haven't
you done a video to him and
man i just feel sick to my stomach every
time i try and think about doing it
mm-hmm
but hopefully we'll help you today but
yeah because i know how hard it can be
to talk about someone you love so much
and you're missing them
yeah and it's still very raw and to be
honest like if you hadn't asked to do
this i would have never suggested it
because it was like
i just want to let you grieve in your
own time but uh
you know if you're feeling like you need
a bit of a jump start uh we're more than
happy to help
you helped us um so to so let's just go
back i guess
and talk about wild man's health issues
and how he ended up in the situation he
did in
so peter went up to
about 28 and a half stone in recent
months
and it's just come back now that we
found out it was
multiple organ failure
so when his dog died he wasn't getting
out the house much i offered to buy him
a new dog
and he refused and it was really buzzing
because we were doing the podcast
together that he was co-interviewing
really good
on one of the podcasts we look down at
his trousers
and they're all wet and we say well
ma'am
why are your legs leaking like that
leaking water
he's alright it's just water i'm gonna
bottle it and bless people
that was his sense of humor to the end
that was his sense of humor
i went home and googled it and it was
actually an ingredient from his blood
and his ankles swelled up like this big
with pus and blood and
they had to put he described it as a
syringe that you would use on an
elephant
into his ankle to extract all the
rhubarb and custard
right i put a video up about six or
seven months ago saying wild man needs
help and hospitalization
this was during the corvid outbreak as
well yeah this
was my first inclination that something
was seriously wrong because
as you know from the stories of the wild
man he has no fear of anything
whatsoever and we can we can get to some
of those stories but
he called me or i called him and
he said i could barely breathe
i'm scared it was the first time i ever
heard fear in his voice so i thought
right something serious is happening
here
we've got to get him in the hospital but
because of corona
and his own brave stance he said that
there are all people dying right now
they need the hospital beds
more than i do so
was there a bit of a pushback from the
hospital when he tried to be treated
yeah yeah they basically told him you've
got to stay at home
call your doctor yeah that was ongoing
the whole time
you couldn't probably get in and get on
a drip and get all the medical attention
that he needed
that could have possibly saved his life
so we just filmed some podcast a couple
of months ago
and we went out for a meal and
he um started to feel
a bit ill during that week we had about
eight eight podcasts scheduled
and he some of the days he couldn't come
in
and i got a request from another guy i
wanted to interview and i ran down all
the wild man symptoms and he said look
he's got to get in hospital he's got to
get on the drip so i caught wild man
said this could be fatal
you got to get in the hospital and
he sent me a response on the text
saying you know he's contacted the
doctors he can't get in the hospital
because of corona not don't worry i love
you i'm going to be all right all this
stuff
and um
he
it's all right mate you just take your
time pal he was rushed hospital he
couldn't breathe and then he [__]
died
just like that sorry bro
you've got to let it open we've been
best friends for like 40 plus years man
it's like
we knew everything we thought i could
finish your sentences we knew what we
were thinking that sounds like we were
like twins
it's just so weird i think he doesn't
exist he does exist though
that's the thing you know that
you always will
you know what i mean yep he's
immortalized on the videos
there's very we've interviewed everyone
the stories of wild man are as legendary
as they kept paul
yeah and you're going to carry that one
yeah and that's what he would want
yeah for sure yeah yeah you would that's
what the day is about
yeah yeah he's looking down on me now
thinking
have my strength go with it have my
strength
go with it yeah
i'm sorry for you honestly i'm so
[__] sorry for you you don't know
he loved you guys yeah yeah well you and
him were like me and lost you know what
i mean
we did joke about that yeah yeah it's
like the
uh future yeah it's it's i'm just so
sorry for you mate yeah
yeah you know because it didn't feel
quite sudden
it was very sudden yeah he was just on
the i was on the phone with him
constantly and he's just cracking his
jokes
you know saying he was going to be all
right he's got doctor's appointments and
bam just like that he was gone they
didn't call him wild man for nothing
he certainly like he lived life on the
edge and when i met him
you know you told us all these stories
and here he comes this larger than life
figure and i'm a [__]
massive guy myself so i'm looking at him
and he's like
whoa you know he's a giant honey you
know he's a giant
it's rare that you meet someone who's
bigger than you
yeah you know what i mean but obviously
like you know he hadn't looked after
himself bless them
and and in all the stories that's one of
the things that fearlessness
and um you know i was watching a few of
our old
podcasts the other day and i was
watching the one we did with him
and you just see him talking and you
think you lived for the moment you made
and and that's got to be applauded in a
way you know and
and often people who do that they do
have an early early
end of their life sadly but what a
[__] life man like
that the way he attacked it i i i
remember
even on the podcast i'm like you didn't
think much of this through before you
did it didn't you
he just went for it you know what i mean
yeah if it sounded like a good idea at
that moment
while he was doing it sometimes he even
felt like a bad idea in that moment i
think he was good
but um you know um what what has been
sort of the process you've been going
through in the days
after is death how is your brain
processing because i find
with death uh they call it the stages
and you know when you hear that you
think oh well everyone goes through the
same thing and we go through
you know your grief your anger all these
things but realistically no one has the
same experiences and no
the stage has come back sometimes and
you go through anger again or whatever
so how are you feeling
so the day i found out was in the
morning when i had
two podcasts scheduled to film
and i found out how did they that you
know who was it who let you know
so i think it was his wife
and his cousin hammy contacted me
i went into a state of shock looking
back now i understand it but i didn't
understand it at the time
so i went and filmed those podcasts how
did they go
how was that in there were you like is
this even happening or kind of did you
just block it out
i don't know because what happened after
the podcast was i went to order some
food
and i was stood at the checkout and
they'd give me the food
and i said to the person i don't know if
i've paid or not i don't know
and i had already paid i didn't know
what was going on
so i just got through the day on
autopilot
it's [__] mad how that happens isn't
it looking back at it
because now i can't even pick a camera
up and do a video yeah and it's two
weeks
later but on the day i found out i went
and did
the podcast like i was supposed to do
and then the next day it just really hit
me your your brain goes into that like
airbag mode where everything's just like
not real
yeah [__] it wasn't real you almost
didn't want to acknowledge it in a way
as well
i couldn't believe he wasn't there
sorry man this is going to happen
throughout this podcast so
you just got to let it happen
it's alright they told me i couldn't
believe
i just went about my day mm-hmm
that's normal mate honestly people deal
with
it took a day
for me for me to realize it happened
you're doing well you know
from everybody and you guys
and all the messages and all the guests
who did tribute videos
the messages that were coming in every
minute um
that really it was like the spirit i
felt
everything just raised you see growing
you've interviewed some of the baddest
men in the br
in britain and you see them bubbling
away on their tributes to the wild man
because obviously
he touched them you know he was one of
them they identified with him he was in
that brotherhood of
bad [__] but also good people
deep down a lot of them
the funny thing is when peter
interviewed them they all look small
yeah next to him big bodybuilder guys
some of the biggest baddest guys they
all look tiny next um
i wasn't um a weightlifter he just
was that big you know she's the force in
nature yeah
larger than life yeah that's what i
thought of when he died you know
yeah yeah i said the tax laws i said
larger than that
i think he knew because on the phone
calls
towards the end of it he was really
telling me how much he loved me and
stuff
i'm glad i'm glad you've had those
conversations though because that's what
carries you through this stuff
mate you know what i mean i'm a firm
believer when people die
it's the strength of the relationship
that we had with them
that actually helps you get through
their death
you know often sometimes
it can go if you if you felt like you
didn't say what you wanted to say or you
didn't have that relationship
you can't get over that situation the
way you can when you did have those
conversations
and those are gonna really help you now
i promise you
they really are and all those hours of
videos you've got together
all those funny moments like when he he
fell asleep in the middle of one of the
podcasts
i remember sending it to lawrence said
i'm like i'm not sure this is kind of
recording the plan yeah
you say
you know all those moments that you had
because you know if you never got into
this
and you guys had just been off camera
and living your lives and telling these
stories
in the pub you wouldn't have them
immortalized the way you do and that's a
real
thankful thing we've got i've been
watching the videos non-stop including
the one you just described
and it went in slow motion around and
tapping
his leg you can see the look in my eyes
like smiling but yeah the guess wasn't
the best out there
it's not a reflection on the guests
i mean he i'll tell you one thing he's
the only man ever to come on this show
and now drink me
so like quite a distance as well i think
he was sick in them
you wouldn't feel this way though if you
hadn't been so close to him you know
it's a reflection we went through the
most intense
wildest emotional scurry
crazy drugged up insane party in
times incarceration times of our lives
together
let's just go back and talk about how
you guys came to be
friends because i think that moment
seems quite clear for you
just growing up in our little town he
was two years younger than me
and i was part of a little gang called
the sweats
and it was peter's oldest brother was
our gang leader
so peter was not allowed to join
and his brother's brother beat him up
and do cruel things and
in the end i splintered off from them
and just started hanging out with peter
and peter just
grew massive in the school
the teachers i think he put a teacher in
a bin because the teacher has
talked some [__] to him right he just
picked the teacher up and put him in a
bin
wow so the teachers then was scared of
him and they had him outside with the
caretaker raking leaves and stuff
he was getting a lot of fights he would
get in nightclubs and
start fights with bouncers and his face
would just
be black and blue like a train had hit
him why why was he starting fights why
was he sort of
like that i guess if you go back
hundreds of years
he would have been like the fearless
person that enjoyed violence the first
person to jump up and protect the
village
right but that kind of person's an
anachronism now
if you watch like braveheart and there's
this big guy called hamish
like that would have been him you know i
mean like we got him at the front
for some reason i've been watching the
vikings non-stop in the last couple of
weeks honestly
he's like one of them yeah he is one of
them yeah yeah like in that era
it would have been completely normal but
in this era
he ends up in prison and all of that you
know i mean in that era he's a hero
so he got in trouble ended up in prison
me and his cousin hammy used to go
up to a quarry on a hill called pax hill
and there was
a tree overlooking it and we called it
the thinking tree
and that's where we set our life goals
and i said to them
i was gonna go to america and make a
million in the stock market and fly you
guys over
and harmony was like yeah you will with
all your shirt trading because he was
aware of what i was doing
while man would say i'm going to prison
because of my red dots
he was saying now he's setting that out
as his goal yeah right yeah he said the
red dots are telling me to hurt people
i'm going to spend the rest of my life
in prison when he says red dots
so he had red dots in his head which he
later described as the red mist but
usually enthusiastically call it as the
red the red dots
and he'd say the red dots are kicking in
telling me to hurt people and i'd say
peter what are the red dots telling you
now and they're telling me to do this
and that it would be some kind of
violent act
and his eyebrow would go up as well when
he was about to actually act
on the red dots right so i would always
know when the eyebrow cocked
oh something crazy was going to happen
you you yourself have uh bipolar i was
diagnosed with that yeah
yeah do you wonder if he was um
suffering from something similar
when you when you hear someone from a
young age talking like that
it reminds me of something my dad would
have said for example you know
whatever he had was magnified by the
drug cocktails that he did because in
america then it just went to the next
level
so this is how old were you when you had
these red dots experiences
so while mum was seeing the red dots
hearing the red dots when he was
like middle teens really yeah that's a
heavy thing to come out with at 15.
so we made a plan to get wild man
to america to become a wrestler to
channel that energy
so he wouldn't get any trouble but he
did end up going to prison in the uk
first
so i'm working away in the stock market
and
he's in prison this is fighting related
prison he ended up in prison because he
was told
that somebody had ecstasy pills
and the person didn't have extra pills
but he i think he knocked the person out
five pounds fell out of the person's
pocket
and wild man went and spent that money
on a kebab
which then constituted street robbery
jesus
so he ends up going prison for this
really stupid defense
for long not for long i can't remember
how many years
but he went from like
prison kind of makes people harder and
rougher of course
do you think that sort of
institutionalized him a bit and made him
like
even more a furious person yeah
because he was maximum
aggression when he came over okay that
first
trip didn't last very long that was the
one that got him banned from america
and deported for being a minister
society so i
rented him a house near the georgian
dragon english pub in central phoenix
thinking
he'll just go and have a beer with the
expats and he'll chill out
and i'll get him this job as a wrestler
while i'm working in the stock market
and then me and
my girlfriend go over to visit him one
night in his
place a couple of months after he's been
in there
and we knock on the door and a bunch of
mexicans answer
and i say was peter and i say peter
pizza we didn't order pizza like no
peter peter he lives here
then we all pull guns out so me and my
bird
like start backpedaling across the road
while man comes just bouncing over the
road smiling
he's like don't worry about them la
they're the local crack dealers the guy
at the back is the
head of dumb he's the colombian he wants
to invest money in the stock market
through yeah
they like to move around a lot so i've
rented them this place out and they're
letting me stay in their place
and they're buzzing because i can do a
hundred dollar crack rock
in one breath and i'd be in there and
he'd be like
there'll be a circle of mexicans with
the colombian crap
dealer well then they'll be in there i'm
wrestling people
and then you do like a hundred dollar
crack rat maybe go red dots
sizzle sizzle red dark sizzle sizzle
and he'd just be looking like this he's
not slept in days
and then he's out his arm wrestling
someone died and smoking crack that was
his existence
and you weren't you weren't training in
the drug game yourself at this point at
that point
i was in the stock market but it was the
connections
that wild man introduced me to during
that first visit
that established the criminal enterprise
wow because he was in multiple
properties in a very short period of
time because you get
getting kicked out of them for dramatic
reasons
so someone came over to buy drugs
off the mexicans a man and a woman a
couple
the woman went over the road to get the
crack of the mexicans because while mum
was back in his apartment now they'd
moved
up over the road and the guy who'd come
over
had a gun well had not seen guns before
and he demonstrated the gun
and shot himself in the head dead so
this was that same story i remember
yeah yeah so i remember yeah obviously
wildman telling the story and he said
the guy puts the country sentiment this
is how we do it in america yeah
and that was such a strange moment
because it it did seem like he didn't
think that there was a
bullet in the chamber at that moment the
way he was pratting around
and wildman's got a dead body right in
front of him out of nowhere
and he's just sitting there going i
didn't do it
yeah but when when the cops come around
they've already had problems with them
the problems with well man and the cops
um
at that point had only been like just
walking around drinking with
open cans and stuff like that nothing
major yet because
this was his first visit and this death
happened
quite quickly he definitely didn't have
anything to do with no because here's
what happened right so
because i know that people listening
might be like this is gonna go yeah the
guy just shot himself
yeah like people you know what i mean
the police aren't that stupid so here's
what happened
i'm in the office i get a call from one
of my family members saying
have you seen headline news i know why
well it's all over headline news peter's
place
right now yellow tape all around it
police say there's been um a shooting
someone's dead
it could be him so i'm thinking holy
[__] it's well man
so i jump in my car leave the office
zoom up there
i've got some drugs in my car and i see
all this police tape
and police vehicles and camera crews
and headline news people and i'm
thinking all right
perhaps i better go and um get rid of
the drugs and come back when things have
calmed down
so i waited until the afternoon
and went back and there was nobody there
at all it was just a police tape
so i go in and
peter's in there with a homicide
detective this guy had a very
serious looking face on him and he said
to me you know who are you
i said well you know i signed for this
place for peter i brought him over
to from england and put him here by the
british pub
and um you know i'm working this in the
stock market and asked for my business
card and stuff
so they did all the tests on peter the
ballistics test and everything because
when someone
shoots themselves the gunpowder residue
is you know obviously on that person
so it clearly showed that peter wasn't
involved in it
now the cop the homicide cop started to
open up to us and this is one of the
most
insane stories i've ever heard in my
life
i said to him you know what kind of
crazy cases do you work on
what's you know because i was always
fascinated by serial killers researching
the book early on here just
trying to get it just shows that it was
in you even then that inquisitive
nature the serial killer thing is so
common when i arrived in arizona there
was a serial killer and there was even a
serial killer of cats that were shooting
cats in people's windows
that seemed less crazy
well he said to me the serial killer
that's killing the joggers and
throwing their heads into salt river
we've kind of got him and i said what do
you mean you've kind of got him
and he said we've got his dna because
what he's doing is he's cutting the
heads off the joggers
and he's skull [__] them so hard that
when he ejaculates
the semen gets embedded so
deep in the skulls that even though
these heads are bobbing up and down on
salt river
the salt river water is not washing the
semen
out of the skulls naturally
i mean this is this is just science
horrible
it's never it's never a normal podcast
with sean just a reminder this podcast
is a tribute to wild man
to be fair i think he'd love it yeah
jesus arizona was not a normal place
anything so this just opens up to you
and you sort of just and and obviously
they're quite proud of this they think
they've sort of caught him in a way
and what do you guys say after that i
mean i was just gobstruck
and i just like was telling people back
at the office and telling my girlfriend
this story i just found out because i
was just amazed
yeah did they catch that serial killer
then i don't know right okay
we should look up to that yeah the skull
[__] killer yeah joggers
yeah in salt river that's it tell you
what like i mean when people say jogging
is good for you
i'm not too sure anymore yeah me either
i think i've been doing the right thing
all these years
i get you're going to watch yourself i
will um so but say
um so what i am curious about is kind of
how would you pick up off the bug
what i'm interested in is obviously when
he first arrived in america
america was quite a different place when
you guys went from america you probably
know now although you know obviously the
trump is president
it does feel like crime was a lot more
easy to get away with back then though
what was what yeah ecstasy trafficking
was but let me tell you what happened
after
you left that house so he moves to a
house on the west side
with two women and a steroid head disco
dancing cowboy bouncer
oh the two women romantically linked to
him no the two women
are like in the drug community
and this guy this this cowboy steroid
head guy thinks he's a big tough guy
and somebody tells me this isn't gonna
end so they're behind on the rent
so i go up check the place out i cut a
check
for this apartment complex on the west
side and
i get a call the next day
from the apartment manager and she says
uh peter's we've
we'll have to evict peter this was
within like a day
i said why she said he's beat his
roommate up
i said well how do you know he's beat
his roommate up what proof do you have
of this
and she said that the roommate
an argument was heard by the neighbors
and there was banging
and the roommate was seen by the
neighbors
running through the apartment with
plasterboard sand
all over his face running through
running for his life through the
apartment
and there are human head sized holes
in numerous of the walls wow so i went
and grabbed peter real quick and said a
lot
what's happened here and peter was like
he was telling me to keep things tidy
and put my dishes away and
stuff like this so just put his [__]
head through the wall
fortunately he'd done it so fast that
they hadn't had time to cash the check
at the apartment
so i managed to stop the check and the
two women
who were living there one of them had a
boyfriend
in tempe arizona which is the university
town this is where the criminal
enterprise
starts is out of this apartment she said
my boyfriend over those behind on his
rent if you fix the situation
while men can move in over there and
that was the apartment complex where
we did the first experiment as shown
in the bank of abroad episode i went out
to california
got that first thousand ecstasy pills i
think we talked about that on the first
podcast
wolf of wall street one those pills are
brought back to wild man's apartment in
that complex called rachel murrieta
those pills were like gone in a weekend
and while my men just threw constant
parties out of that apartment russian
mafia italia mafia mexican mafia
transgender female street prostitutes
gang bangers it was just non-stop
and that's how i made all the criminal
connections that enabled me to establish
the criminal enterprise was through
peter
was that the place to be then that was
sort of was that considered cool like
did you feel cool when you first started
do you think
you felt cool yeah yeah the thing with
me and peter is i had anxiety as a
teenager
a wild man were just walking anywhere
and on the place
and that opened the door to me to make
friendships with people
because you was with him you felt a
safer yeah but also all the attention's
on him as well
so it's kind of like you can relax a bit
and not feel that anxiety as much
and obviously the ecstasy was helping
that's what i wanted to see i had the
false courage from the drugs
and wildman always would say you know
i've got your back i'd take a bullet for
you
and things like that and god bless him
he did have the heart of a mountain lion
and he would take a bullet for me but
some of the situations probably put our
lives more in danger than
we um yeah yeah we'll get to that though
i guess what i'm curious about is
obviously he's new in town he's walking
around with an open bottle
and you say the police are stopping him
yeah yeah is this like
jay walking with budweiser's and stuff i
guess what i'm trying to
gauge is then is this the same police
officer stopping him over again and
being like
same guy again here or is phoenix such a
big place i don't know what the
atmosphere is like like
how much of a wave you guys are making
because to me when you say mexican mafia
turning up you know russian mafia
prostitutes all this sort of thing
i feel like i'd notice that do you know
what i mean if that happened in my
apartment block
and it sounds like there's you guys are
attracting a lot of attention but i
can't work out where you are or not okay
so this is not like a small town this is
a
massive city that's just
very transitional a lot of people coming
in and out i don't know how many
millions of people live
in phoenix and tempe is like a big
suburb of it which is a university town
and they have multiple giant
apartment complexes you just disappear
into them yeah
we would have like someone in the front
building
would be like selling the pills in the
next building back there'll be someone
with cash
and then you'd have like protection in
another building
but that's how we structured it over
time so you kept everyone close together
yeah it was well well organized yeah and
who was that you who organized that or
was that between you and my like what
was wild band's role with
wellman's role was
to i mean
like i said he's a force of nature so
whatever he did he did and he just
naturally progressed into the person who
everybody was scared of
right so he they would pay their debts
he didn't have to beat them up he would
just move in with them
and that was the biggest thing that
walman would move him because if walmart
moved in with you
so if you're in debt he's moving in yeah
he's moving in and
so are all of the people of the night
he's partying with like within the first
day
there's a [__] in your kitchen cooking
up crack
you've got um transgender you know
prostitutes prostitutes coming in native
american
gang bangers and there's nothing you
could do about it the mexican mafia
people are taking your tv their runners
are taking your tv and your
uh other appliances and you're just
staring at this
and there's absolutely nothing you can
do about it so that's that's how
people were kept in line they were
afraid that peter would move in with
them it felt like
so correct me if i'm wrong here but
obviously you were the brains of the
situation generally speaking
and it felt like wild man the way he
he the way he looked after you you sort
of look after him in turn in a different
kind of way because he's there
and he's enjoying all of the fruits of
the labor and he's getting as many drugs
as he wants he's doing whatever the [__]
he wants
and all he has to do basically is be the
big heavy
and be the threat and as long as
there's no problems he's going to keep
having a good old time that was it he
just had a good old time
and he was very good at talking to
people so just going back to what
lawrence was saying then
so if a cop caught him jay walking with
a budweiser
i'm over here from england i'm on
holiday right i'm visiting
visiting my cousin and sean you know
innocent
buzzing enough you know they don't have
you know it just be buzzing uh and he
did that he did have quite a sort of i
know it's a weird thing to say about
someone who's
obviously a heavy for quite a big drug
organization but he did have quite a
charming smile and quite
kind eyes and i've been watching his
videos in the past week
and he's the funniest [__] on
the place of the uh he's very
charismatic yeah
he's charismatic and just he's so honest
he just says anything that comes into
his head
no matter how non-politically correct
you'll just say it
and our people love that authenticity
about him
he seems a bit after meeting him and
seeing all those videos and all the
stories there's a bit of a jekyll and
hyde thing though
so it's like on the one hand if he
respects and likes you he's warm
big cuddly bear big caring guy but on
the other hand
there's a couple of photographs where
you see the mean
dark side that he had within him as well
and there's a complete opposite there's
a there's a
there's a scary thing going on there
where you you would literally kill
someone if he had to
you know what i mean i'll tell you the
story of the giant i don't think i've
ever told you the story of the giant
so meanwhile mandarin some like dodgy
pool hall slash biker bar place where
you know it's ex-vietnam vets with scars
on their faces and
crystal meth users did you ever think
not to hang out in these places
yeah you know when you tell us all these
stories i'm always like well you took
yourself there if you'd have just gone
to the gym for the day maybe you know go
to the library read a few books that was
the fun of it i was on
an adventure with peter did you seek it
out do you think
did you seek it out a little bit do you
think sometimes even though i had an
exercise
when i was on drugs i was balls to the
wall
i would i would go full-on as well no i
didn't like violence
ever but i did like the excitement and
just the insaneness of the party scene
and of course you were best friends with
wildman but you didn't like violence
ever
that's the thing though it's it's it's a
bit like having a rottweiler
or whatever isn't it it's like that
there's a funness about
not knowing what can happen next time
exactly not knowing what can happen next
nurse
becomes quite addictive and you two
would you two would sort of
do that together because you were both
in it together so you know i guess you
two would go we'll go here today and the
other one would just go with
he liked to
gravitate towards the most dangerous
environments
the dodgiest bars the streets
that had like pink hotel rooms where you
pay by the hour so you can
get a sex worker off the corner and
she'll
be able to bring over the local crack
dealer they're the environments he loved
to be in
and he said to me that when there was
complete chaos
around him what you know when tvs had
been thrown through windows and gunshots
were going off
and crack dealers were coming over
um he could relax fall asleep finally
brian says a very similar thing to me
actually yeah this is a mod isn't it
so so to take my back to this biker ball
you've got the
probably the hell's angels or whoever
else in there um
and you know he's there you're there
what happens next
we're in the bar playing pool i think
we're high on crystal meth
well mans this bar is quite close to
does that affect your pool skills just
out of them yeah it enhances them
i ended up on the georgian dragon pool
team
i was doing jump shots i was [__] hard
on crystal meth
because in the beginning
the extra alertness
and you thinking you can accomplish
anything the confidence it gives you
in the beginning enhances your skills
so in the long run the side effects kick
in and destroy everything but in the
beginning
there's a little window of good at least
right yeah there's something
i heard about uh pilots microdosing on
amphetamines because it keeps them
so sharp and a lot of them end up
struggling with it military power
military give
pilots speed and this is why taxi
drivers and lorry drivers are huge
customers for speed
to keep them alert while they're driving
keep them on the road it's amazing
isn't it so so you're on there you're
playing your pool sitting in every shop
doing jump shots you know the great
thing about that is so when you're first
there and you're very alert fantastic
after a while you can't tell whether the
shot's going in or not anyway
okay and a giant comes in
this is another guy who's a big butt big
man this is
a giant this guy is like seven foot ish
with a funny chin
and the funny teeth and he looks like
not quite andre the giant the wrestler
bought from
cut from the same mold i'm imagining
that uh the guy off the james bond
movies
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i look at the giant i look at wild
man
and the eyebrows like this have they had
any beef or this just like
he's just looking at him going you're
alpha male i'm an alpha male
this is going to happen the two biggest
guys in the room basically just look at
each other
well while one's looking at him like
pray this guy's my prey
right so i say peter
don't and his eyes are just like he's
been up for days on crack and his eyes
are completely red and there's nothing i
can do to stop him
so he walks up to the giant and holds
his hands out
and he says my name's peter [__] no
what's your name and the giant says his
name
and peter starts squeezing the giant's
hand
and this is just not politically correct
at all i'm not condoning what peter said
and while man says if i were you
i'd be in the circus you [__] freak
and the giant looks down with his
bugged out eyes now cause what did you
just say
while man goes you [__] heard me
if i were you i'd be in the circus you
[__] freak
so the lot the hands are locked and the
giant's like this
and wild man just looks like the devil
he's been up for like
god knows how long he's just looking up
like this like the devil
the giant's looking down there's a
standoff and people
are watching and in the end it just all
reversed
and they made friends what do you mean
it just reversed
they didn't fight so who broke i can't
remember exactly
okay all i remember is thinking
and the giant goes come outside i want
to show you my car
so we went outside and the giant
had a special car where he was sitting
in the back
of it because his legs were so long and
he gave us his number
peter was targeting me like i said he's
got the gift of gab and he gave us his
number and pete was like yeah
come and hang out with us and party with
us and um
we can come come that collecting with
with the uh
the mexicans and he's like yeah you know
i'm up for that and he gave us his
number
we lost his number can you imagine a
wild man
and a giant showing up at your door you
owe us money
jesus i don't know i feel like well
we're talking about memories and they're
good memories of yours yeah
but i know you have very soft some soft
memories of
as well the way he isn't the big bru who
wants to fight everyone but he is a bit
of a general guy and stuff like that
have you got any more memories like that
where you feel like
was that later on in his life where he
mellowed a bit and he was a bit more
gentle with you
when we all first got arrested there was
a group of 13 of
us and half of them were women
and we've been through processing with
tempe police and we're all in a van then
they take us over to the madison street
jail
this is may 2002
all the new arrestees are outside of the
jail this place
is crazy you've got
gangbangers drug dealers
homeless rival gang members threaten
each other
people who are high people who are drunk
people have been tasered
people beat up by the cops so you got
quite a lot of them are quite maniacal
people who are in who are
waiting to get into the jail and they're
mostly men
so our women get out of the policeman
and all these male prisoners turn around
and start heckling the women saying
sexually suggestive stuff
so while man gets out after the women
while the women are still getting
heckled
and he's coming down i don't know if
they had some like little steps
you have to come down in your chains and
he looks like a viking
he's got a bit of a beard he's got his
chains
and he's just the police are like get
down the steps get down the steps and he
just stops on the steps
and ignores the cops and he looks at all
of the men heckling the women
and says
stop talking [__] to our women or else
i'll have any of you [__] when
we all get in that jail
and he just locks down his beard at him
like he's gonna [__]
smash their heads into toilets as soon
as he gets in
and they all shut the [__] up
because you sent some emails with
pictures of you and white man which
we'll probably be showing throughout
this anyway yeah and i think a lot of
people obviously know wild man
now and had to kind of visualize what he
was like as a younger man
you know but he was there was something
quite striking about the way he looked
and you say his beard and
he was quite a different there was
something a bit mellow about him
as he was older wasn't there whereas
when he was younger i think you could
those pictures you sent me you can see
the wildness in both of you in a way
like you've got some crazy haircuts in
that there's one i think there's one
photo of you with
stripes shaved into your head yeah yeah
that was in the rave scene in the uk
that one
yeah yeah did you two kind of encourage
the other to be a little more out there
as well did you
get to encourage you we fed off each
other
and that's how our insaneness went to
such a high level
but after that insane this and after
obviously the criminality if that's what
you want to call it i don't know after
what you after what you did
did you two also reflect together on
that and kind of um
i know work out how you felt about some
of the wrong or some of the
the the more because there's a lot of
stories here we're laughing along
yeah but obviously some people have come
to harm in those yes and
did you two do reflection together on
that so wild man
became more philosophical and started to
call himself
mild man in recent years
and he said he's got no regrets
whatsoever
he's lived life to the fullest and he's
not an apologist he's not going to
apologize to anyone
i do talk to schools and stuff like that
and
you know i have to go in and show the
consequences of you know drug taking and
things like that and
my mom had a nervous break then explain
all these things so i've got all these
things that i do
genuinely agree i saw the harm that
people on drugs it causes i put people
on the road with drugs i saw the horror
of that in the jail
but wild man was more
um i've done these things ain't gonna
[__] look back
i'm getting on with my life all i can do
now is try and do good
and he did try and do good a lot of
people contacted him
saying they were inspired by his story
to get off
alcohol to get off drugs people said
they were suicidal
i've seen the messages and hearing
wildman's story and the humor and the
inspiration it gave them prevented them
from killing themselves
so he became this iconic figure that
inspired people because
he'd been through such a crazy life and
committed these
heinous acts what come out the other
side
and had reversed that successfully you
know you know looking back at his
childhood and stuff like that because we
didn't i don't know if we really got a
chance to delve into that
uh do you think that that was part of
the reason he became
wild in the way he was good grief so
i've had to contemplate nature versus
nurture
in the case of wild man and
i think it's so complex that you can't
just nail it down to one thing but
perhaps the combination of him growing
so big versus his other brothers
his older brother he used to beat him up
a lot
and he used to talk about that a lot to
me
and perhaps the suppression of that
and then he'd go out and fight bouncers
perhaps he was angry you know
when he used to talk about his brother
beating him up though yeah do you think
that scored him a little bit
yeah definitely yeah yeah because um
it's funny in mma and ufc and stuff
you see uh some of the biggest baddest
dudes are the ones who had older
brothers
who used to get beaten up by those
brothers and it spurred them on to learn
how to [__]
fight you know what i mean and do you
think that was sort of maybe the
thinking
i think when he was going down and
fighting multiple bouncers
as a teenager he probably saw his
brother's uh his brother on you know
thinking about his brother the anger he
had
and that's what but i don't want to say
anything disrespectful to the families
no at the end of the day that you know i
think everyone has their
regrets in life and i'm sure you know he
probably did things to his family and
they did things to him and we all hurt
each other at times and that's just part
of it in it you got to let that go now
yeah and remember who he was i just
think it's fascinating to know how you
end up like this because
characters like wild man you know you
say them on grand theft auto and like
you think that's
a bit exaggerated in it and then you
meet a man like wild man and you're like
[__] up
like it reminds me of my own dad a
little bit to be honest my dad's a bit
like this you know i mean yeah
just the rules don't apply to him you
know you could be walking past someone
like him in the street
you wouldn't really think twice about oh
well you know i could probably have him
or whatever
but people like him who'll bite your
face off or something you don't really
know what you're getting involved with
until it's too late
the rules did not apply at all and
that's how i learned during his first
visit
that my intention to get him a job as a
wrestler was
idealistic because once he got kicked
out of
the final apartment the one i described
where we were partying out that was
completely stripped of all the furniture
and everything
he had lit some kind of plastic in the
air conditioning duct
so that when the little blobs of blue
plastic flame fell down they made this
little
noise that soothed his red dots and he'd
let fire extinguishers off in there and
everything just for the hell of it
people were coming in through the
windows to get drugs it was just so out
of control
the police ended up raiding that one
and he um was under
living under a tree with a stripper
taser girl living under a tree with his
girlfriend who was the stripper who
tasered her vagina
with a rambo knife for those who don't
know she she became his girlfriend just
sorry to reject me when he met her at a
party
and she already had her boyfriend and he
told the boyfriend to go
[__] off basically and he was mr steal
your girl basically that night he
he told the guy to go make spaghetti
bolognese or something like that and
then
took the woman yeah took the woman and
they were together then until he got
deported
being society so he was living under
this this tree
they were doing like bunny and clyde
stuff just going in restaurants ordering
meals finding you know steaks and just
not even paying on the
complete rampage and that that was how
he ended up
um gets deported and classified as a
minister society
but it was the connections that i
established through him that enabled me
to build the business
and through when he was in his prime
what were his sort of
the the most violent things that he
actually carried out
in that you witnessed personally or
heard about
if there was a situation i'd i saw him
knock a few people out
yeah he he um he had a left punch didn't
he
what was that left hook was it and they
just break out like that
one punch yeah but there was i was at an
apartment party once
and g-dog was there and someone
actually got the better of him because
wildman would
he knew when a big guy was gonna punch
him out
and he'd usually like offer to shake
hands with the right
and punch the big guy out with his left
before the big but someone did it to him
once um we was at this
apartment party i was just off my face
on ecstasy just enjoying the vibe
and it was just really chill gee dog was
in the
and i think it was like a baseball
player
for asu
some jock and this guy he wasn't as tall
as wild man but he was
stocky and you could see he was strong
but he was an athlete strong as [__]
yeah yeah yeah so he came over
and okie doked wild man and punched
swellman in the head
um i think he might have like pretended
to be wild man's friend just hit him
but it didn't not well man elm so
this apartment was just full of people
like walter wall
and this thing broke out and it was like
oh i remember feeling like i was in a
wave of people and i'm on ecstasy and
this wave of people
and wild man's trying to get him this
way and the waves going that way then
people are pulling well then back and
the wave is going that way
and i i think gee dog pulled a gun on
the guy or something and we had to leave
in a hurry
yeah that solves a lot of issues though
doesn't it you don't
clean things up like that without it
escalating
he was very shrewd and streetwise was he
the third of the
the duo then yeah he was
when he was out of prison he was
definitely the third of the duo he was
someone who i trusted with my life
and he was like the bridge into that
world of the mexican mafia new mexico
wild man had uh just as crazy
with fighting as he was with his romance
and
i remember one story about he basically
says to his missus in the uk
i'm going for a paper and then
he gets on a plane for the first time in
his life by the way he's never flown
he'd never been on holiday and he flies
all the way
to arizona to be with you and doesn't
tell her
anything he just goes away and that's it
for god was how long
but when you look back at his uh
relationships with women or whatever who
was
who were his main relationships with and
what were they like
all right so full props and respect to
his wife right now
i thought while man would spend the rest
of his life in prison like he had
predicted in the thinking tree
and once he met his wife and they moved
in together he never got in trouble with
the police again
so for her to have such a positive
influence on him
this was after he came back this is
after he came from arizona
yeah with the newspaper luckily this is
um
not wild woman this is a woman he met
after he got
um deported the final time um so this
was later on in his life then yeah this
is in the last years of his life yeah
so going back to the wild woman
was his main misses
in the 1990s the late 19 mid to late
1990s
this is bonnie and clyde no no that was
his stripper
my body the stunning yeah yeah so the
first time wild man came
out he told wild woman
that he was going to just go the news
agents and get a milk or something
newspaper or something and he did hook
up with
the taser girl while he was in arizona
and that became then because while woman
comes
later doesn't she okay so yeah so
his his first main relationship in the
uk
was with wild woman no actually his
first
main relationship in the uk was with the
mother of his daughter
all right okay so we did set up a
donation page for his
daughter and um we'll put the link for
that in the description yeah yeah
thanks to people who've donated i think
it's raised almost three grand wow yeah
and she has just recently had
um a grandchild so wild man was proud
that he was a granddad
bless him well we're glad he got to see
that situation yeah yeah what was he
like as a grand as a granddad do you
think
i don't want to say too much because his
daughter and grandchild want to remain
anonymous yeah
and they live overseas but yeah he was
touched but he was he was really proud
of them really proud of you yeah it's a
big moment in your life isn't it yeah
yeah
i'm old now yeah exactly yeah it makes
you feel old it makes you feel
even better let alone granddad so yeah
that's incredible for him yeah
so that was with his first um his first
woman in the uk
yeah but like he said on
on another interview because wildman's
only been to me by two people that's you
and helen wood and he told her
i think he may have told you as well
that he wasn't ready to settle down at
that young age
he felt trapped in a house with
responsibilities
and he wasn't ready to be a dad the call
of the wild
was the so they broke up
and then wild man got in trouble for the
street robbery
went to prison i'm in america working
the stock market
he meets wild woman and she became known
as wild woman because she took out an
entire family
in a bar fight with a chair in a pub
so she became the wild woman of witness
separately to him being the wild man of
witness which was a name given to him by
his uncle bob
so so they were all both known for that
reason
and had never even met each other yet
yep wow yeah this is like it's like a
weird sort of disney fairy tale
yeah they were meant to be from the
start yeah yeah yeah
and then he saw her in a pub and asked
her to get her tits out or something
as you did as she did what just on the
spot just sort
the the romantic language they used to
each other was equally
not politically correct right i can
imagine them sort of comparing the
damage they've done
before yeah i have spoke to a wild woman
recently on facebook and asked if she
will come on my podcast and give us her
story and some wild man stories
that'd be lovely that would really fill
in some blanks right
yeah you must have a lot of those
considering all the drugs you did as
well
yeah there's so his you know every day
with him was a story because he would
get up to something so there's just so
many
untold stories out there so why woman
was yeah what was their relationship
like generally
this sounds terrible but how do i phrase
this correctly
they were both violent people
and they thrived on that so
i would go over and i know while one
wouldn't want me to not say this because
i've written about in the book she's
given me permission
they would have fights like he'd hit her
she'd stab him in the belly she'd like
pick up an eye and try and
hit him and you know
and then so this what you're suggesting
is this isn't the case of um
domestic abuse in regards to one party
on the other and a victim
they're both just as bad as each other
yeah their relationship was based on
domestic violence for a period of time
and i tell them both you're gonna kill
each other
she stabbed his belly he showed me all
the scars
what all the scars which all the scars
what with like uh
just pick up a knife sorry she stabbed
him on more than one occasion in more
than one place
this was foreplay for them and this is
what i'm saying i go over shocked at the
mayhem the destruction
it you know thrown a boulder through a
window and stuff and
front windows are smashed and i say you
guys have got to separate you're going
to kill each other
i was completely shocked by the levels
that they took things here they knew it
stressed me the [__] out but
they'd always call me over to try and
clean it up so i'd separate them
the sex must have been mental by the way
that's what they said yeah the next day
they were like
love you love you make up sex time
right you'd still be there right
triangulate in the middle of this
thinking how the [__] can this be
yeah that's that's what good sex does
make it literally keeps
keeps people who are terrible for each
other together for too long
but they were tight partners in crime if
anyone
went against them they would turn on
that person oh jesus
and people were more afraid of her than
him right yeah that makes sense as well
from what you've just said yeah i mean
if if you'll stab your own boyfriend
multiple times in the belly what the
[__] she gonna do to you pal yeah she
loves him
so sorry
this is who i love yeah you're seeing
the scores so when he wasn't around
if people owed money she'd be like i'll
[__] come over and slit your [__]
throat [__]
it's a highly unusual life those two
lived though isn't it like those are the
kind of people where
you know you hear about them in your
town and you sort of go definitely stay
away from that family sort of thing you
that's quite an unusual way to live does
that make sense to you
yeah do you think people knew about them
and were sort of scared of them or what
was their
what was their reputation like people
were in awe of them right because
arizona is a fast-paced place where
there's a lot of people trying to rip
each other off and people don't stay
around for very long
but the wild mans were dominating that
scene so they were actually successful
in what they were doing you say
yeah this is how street wise they were
when the altercation with skinner
occurred which are described in the
previous wolf of wall street podcast
skinner was my top sales guy
he was my right-hand man when while mum
before wildman came to the country
and when wildman came over skinner got
jealous of the amount of time
i was spending with well man so things
escalated with him and wild man
and skinner coordinated a black
gang to fire bomb wild woman's
apartment while while woman was in
deportation
federal are waiting to be kicked out of
the country yet again
was that was there a reason for that
just over because because wildman was in
in prison skinner thought he could get
away with this
and it was it was also set up whereby he
wanted to take wild woman's pills
yeah sorry i meant why was wild woman
awaiting deportation no well man sorry
my bad yeah
he's in prison okay federal deportation
prison so she's sitting there like a
duck basically
that's what skinner thinks but this is
how tough she is
so she's got a pills of stuff in this
place
firebomb comes through the window almost
sets fire to her
this crew of black gangsters that skin
has recruited
show up and say come with us
we work with sean grab your [__] as in
your pills get in the car
we'll you know we'll we'll we'll keep
you safe
while a woman says i don't know who the
[__] you [__] are
do you think i was born [__]
yesterday i just got off the [__]
banana boat do i look like i'm so
[__] stupid
i'm gonna get in the car with you
[__]
and they're like what the [__] you know
so not the normal reaction
the pills were not jacked let's put it
that way
wild woman protect our interests and she
had her own
goons as well that that would do things
for her
so she was his second main partner in
his life wild woman
if you when you say second main the
funny thing the thing that came to mind
is in the criminal
conspiracy in the crime family
the prosecutor had labeled her as number
two
i was in your number two wild man was
they had labeled as my number three
wow yeah because she was that important
to the setup
yeah wow and they had her pegged with a
hundred and
i think it was 155 felonies when all the
[__] went down i think wildman had a
couple of dozen i had a couple of dozens
she was actually
like you see this is the thing the women
are a bit more like
i don't know women everywhere just
instantly here's
sorry what what are you gonna say here
right but like i would be more scared of
a woman
like that than any man do you understand
what i mean by that
yeah like women can be a bit more a man
can forgive very quickly
i feel like women are a little bit they
hold on to [__] more they're more
calculated sometimes and that can make
her really effective
you know what i mean some people do say
there's no more of an element of
kamikaze in the female side
i think is that i mean every man who's
listening now knows exactly what the
[__] we're talking about when you're
trying to put the brakes on
oh i'm sorry she's going i'll [__]
make sure you are
yeah well wild man could just go in and
demolish anyone
while woman could do that but she also
was strategic mmm
calculated then and she would fight men
yeah she would grab someone
and just [__] box him in right in
front of everyone
it was attractive to wildman the fact
that they were like
violent cave people on the same
wavelength
that's what they got off on she was the
female him i suppose in a way yeah
yeah yeah was it a soulmate kind of
relationship oh yeah they were really
tight yeah
yeah definitely i suppose if you know
you'll kill for each other there's an
element of closeness that comes with
that
even if you're trying to kill each other
in the process but then the amount of
drugs they were both on just made the
behavior
ten times more extreme than it was
probably would have been so what
who was the next woman who came after
wild woman
okay so there was wild woman
who came and went because she had a
deportation or two as well
and then there was wild man had
relationships with some
uh striptease women that wild woman
found out about that caused many
arguments and fights including the taser
how did he explain that away just out of
interest do you remember any of the
executives he would
sort of use or so i'd show up and while
i'm going to say
sean's taking me to play pool
a while ago you think i look like
chopped [__] liver
i know you [__] are going to
the titty bar
well i'm [__] coming with you i'm
[__] getting in that car i'm [__]
coming with you
no you're not love we're just gonna go
and play pool just stay right there
you should march in a [__] car and
try and get in the car well i was like
no you're not coming with us we've got
to collect that you got to do this
and i just drive off and leave them to
it sometimes
but no excuses do you so when he when
she did find out was he the kind of guy
to go
or was he just like yeah you caught me
oh yeah he didn't hide anything when he
was found out
he was always honest about everything i
do like that i think it is important
when you're banking right it's just
taking like a month yeah you know what i
mean yeah
whatever so in terms of relationships
though who was the next relationship you
had after
after her all right so we had the
liaisons with the striptease women but
the main relationships had
in his life with the mother of his baby
wild woman
and then his wife when he came back
after his final deportation and that
seemed like a completely different
situation
to everything before that yeah was that
a bit more warm and
loving and so completely and i think he
reflected in prison
that he would just spend the rest of his
life in prison if he kept
up that behavior okay all he did then
was drank and smoked weed
once he got out that final time yeah and
he
he you know he didn't he never went to
pubs because he knew we were getting
fights and then
he would get back in prison so a lot of
indoors just stayed home
complete yeah what was the
the effects of alcohol and weed from
versus everything
before that did was it a lot softer by
comparison oh yeah because i'm crystal
meth he's been up for days
and i it was hard for me
to steer his behavior
away from self-destruction and him
getting arrested
um i'll give you one example so
i had a bouncer called rossetti
it was a big guy big strong guy and i
would tell him all these stories about
peter and i are you no he's gonna get
here eventually we're bringing him back
you you wait and see
so when peter came they both
came to my house on the mountainside in
tucson
and um he said peter was just picking me
up and throwing me around like i'm a rag
dog i can't believe how strong he is
and in the night that night peter went
off into
um the hills
where there was the rattlesnakes and the
cactus
and the next day we just found peter
asleep on the porch like a bird
with his top off completely covered in
cactus spines
and the sun's coming down over the
desert there's big ber figures there
with all these cactus
spines and me and my wife are plucking
all the cactus spines out of his
out of his body but to get to the point
i'm making about him out of control on
meth
so me and rosetti were driving home from
a rave
and while man's in the back seat
and i'm looking in the mirror and his
eyes are just
the devil just pure red and he's just
looking at me in the in the car mirror
think your stuff is not quite right here
so looking over at rosetti
walking back at well man looking back in
the mirror he's just still looking at me
not blinking
i said is everything okay peter it's
like no
so what's the matter peter i know what
you're up to
[__] hell i look at rosetti
like what the [__] what are we up to
peter
i know too much
you guys are taking me out of the desert
right now
so i'm thinking if he thinks we're
taking him out to the desert
he's about to do something to us to
prevent us
taking him out to the desert so i'm
like peter calm down we're your best
mates we love you
we're not taking you up to the desert
you've done too much math
and that's where xanax came in really
handy
i'm sorry it's just we had to douse the
[__] out of him on xanax so many times
when he got like down just to prevent
him from doing destruction yeah while a
woman would douse the [__] out of him on
xanax as well
you know when he came back to the uk and
obviously he's not on that level of
drugs anymore
yeah did you find he compensated for the
the old ways by overdoing it on alcohol
and weed or
do you think it's a sad thing because
i had to address my inner turmoil and my
addiction issues
and i learned to recycle my energy from
negative stuff into positive addictions
but wild man was never able to shake
completely his addiction issues
he substituted the hardcore stuff
for drinking every single day and that's
what did he mean one of the factors
yeah we see the younger photos of him
and obviously he was always a big man
but he became a huge man later on and do
you think the alcohol was probably one
of the reasons
completely so he said the reason he
wanted to do the podcast with me in the
beginning
was to make money to buy beer
and cider you just said it jokingly you
know
but every time we did podcasts
on when i was dropping him off back at
home he would make me stop at bargain
booze
and he'd go in and buy tons of beer and
cider
and i remember i went into bargain booze
with him once
and either the size of the multi-liter
cider bottle had
been reduced or the price had gone up
and his eyebrow went up
and he looked at the poor woman behind
the counter
and he's like what the price what the
but over time because i think we've been
doing podcasts for a couple of years the
youtube videos a couple years while i'm
on the channel
over time i noticed the deterioration of
his health because wellman started to
say
when you take me to bargain booze i need
you to park on the handicapped spot
because i can't walk very well
and his dog had died and i wanted to get
him a new dog to get him walking again
but
just going immobile and sat there
drinking
that was like the final things then that
led yeah
it's hard to talk about for your
understanding and sort of think about as
well because
he's he's always been a mountain of a
man such a strong guy
the most feared man in the room but in
terms of the alcohol
i i've been there a bit myself you know
there's times where i've
used it to numb pain and
um you know people look down on people
who do that but they shouldn't because
we've all been there we've all felt pain
and sometimes
you just can't you can't carry on
without something it's all right
he's not in any pain anymore though and
that's what you need to remember
you know while we're on it actually um i
remember about a year ago i was drinking
quite a lot you know what i mean
and you think to yourself [__] i know i
you know
i can see how people end up carrying on
like this
you know because i was just smashing the
booze
and you think yourself if you can't pull
yourself out of that it's the only way
i keep thinking what could i've done to
save them
keep thinking i should have been up
there but he won't [__] listen to me
i could have got him in the dark and
everything
you offered everything forced into going
to hospital
you just kept joking about it
my brain in the last few weeks we're
going over oh
thinking what can i do
sean you know that there's not a man
alive on this planet who could tell that
man what to do
no one not even you me that's true he
loved you
as much as he loved daniel it's true
yeah but he did what he wanted when he
wants and there was no rules for him
yeah there's nothing you could have done
us admit and i'm not saying this to
alleviate your guilt
because it's the truth
i'm not a bullshitter i wouldn't just
say this to make you feel better that's
the truth mate
yeah even remember when we did the
podcast with them
just getting a video podcast you know
he wasn't in a controllable everything
that would be what he wanted you know
what i mean
he was he was that's who he was yeah
he lived by his own rules and you have
to
respect that as well if he wanted to get
pissed every day
unfortunately that that was not going to
stop him i'll speak to him every week
man and he just joked and said he was
okay
i said it's [__] serious peter you
could die he's like i've seen
the doctors have done everything i can
they can't put me in the house but
because of corona
yeah you did the most from you did a lot
that you could for him
yeah him getting up and going and doing
that podcast with you must have been one
of the most fun things
that could have happened to him with
that period of his lifetime oh he loved
it he loved
the podcast he did but but for him it
could have been quite easy for him to
just disappear into
a man who used to be something and you
know
the stories in the pub are one thing but
really
becomes a bit of a a guy or i used to
have this
and now he's still someone because of
everything you've done and
yeah and he got a lot of enjoyment out
of that and it became like uh
i don't know something later on in his
life to enjoy and have you know what i
mean where
a lot of people don't get that they
become yesterday as hard man
and that's the end of them really and it
didn't happen to him like he was so
proud that he had over a million views
on his true jody podcast
telling me there's a very limited club
of beethoven
ksi it started to rise it must have
started to rise all of a sudden in like
this year because he kept going on about
it but admit it i'm pretty sure it's him
ksi and a porn star i've probably got
the top
and he's prettiest of the three as well
if i'm honest when over a million people
when over a million people care about
you know what he's got to say
that speaks volumes you know i mean he's
a fascinating guy i think that's the
difficult part isn't it when someone's
first gone in your life and it can feel
like they've not
you don't you feel such a a loss that it
feels like
you know they're gone but he really left
a mark
on well more than one mark on this world
i think that's
you really helped him do that yeah you
know yeah
i think there's over a hundred videos on
his playlist and a lot of them he
interviewed
like people he idolized when he was a
kid like brian cockle the tax man
it was one of the most feared and
strongest guys in the country
and um brian was like to the end brian
was like
calling him up and telling it trying to
coach him on health matters and stuff
like that so to have this relationship
with a guy he idealized as a kid
um was really important to him he ended
up with quite different interviews as
well i think didn't he like obviously
that's all well and good
us going oh yeah tell us about your
stories
but when you're sitting opposite someone
who you know is just as bad as you i
think you open up in a different way
don't you and you you i don't know you
almost want to impress them in a way i
think i felt like whenever i watched his
stuff
they wanted to impress him they wanted
to you know yeah yeah
because he's then you can just look in
his eyes and see he's the real deal he's
been through it
and other people have been through
things there's a mutual respect because
i noticed when i was asking questions
of some guys when while man sat there
when it's like the real gangster stuff
they're like in the zone with each other
while when they're done
yeah yeah yeah they're on that that
wavelength aren't they like real
recognized real let's do it yeah
yeah because they know it yeah yeah
other dogs look at him with euros
there's a long time of his life where he
was in prison
of course how did he find that because
being a wild man
you know you're not really controllable
that must have
been difficult really difficult for
someone like that
so you asked me about funny stories and
i've got some funny ones
so in the very beginning then may 2002
we were all arrested and put in
towers jail but the prosecutors got do
not house together on meanwhile
man so we're in separate towers
but we are allowed to go to the church
together um
wow this is like prison break
it really is isn't it how the [__] did
they let you anyway near each other
after that
let me set the table these people call
church on the street
lovely people there was pastor walt
and there was hillbilly bill with his
little banjo
and every now and then there was um
hillbilly ed sorry i think it was there
was jumping bill who would come in
and jumping bill was just this this bald
guy with glasses and a jesus t-shirt and
he'd come in with his guitar and all the
tell the prisoners all start pogo
dancing and
it freaked the guards out and he'd run
up and down the road just beaming and
smiling in people's faces
so we're at church on the street one
time
or was it catholic mass was it from
catholic math
we would sit in the back rows with the
italian mafia guys that we were clicked
up with
and wildman could not whisper
so we're trying to like you know update
our cases and everything what's going on
wildman's voice is just so loud he had a
boom involved yeah
so in church on the street pastor walt
would be like
it stopped they stopped the mass he'd be
like in the end times predicted in the
bible revelations there will be mockers
and scoffers
and right now there are mockers and
scoffers on the back row
and he'd walk right up to the wild man
and he was like you guys gonna shut up
like wow man you've got to learn to
whisper so
catholic mass we're in we're on the back
row of in a whisper
the priest comes out and does holy
communion and some people are very
religious in these services i mean the
front row they're all tatted out with
like jesus and murray tattoos and stuff
and there are already you know
because wildman's whispering some of the
the more devout are already turning
around and going shut up you shut the
[__] up trying to trying to get him to
shut up he doesn't care
but the priest comes up and goes wild
man communion
since the priest turns around he takes
out his mouth puts it on his eye like
he's a pirate with an eye patch
he goes look at me everyone look at me
i worship the devil and if he grabs
the communion the priest by now is
almost walked
to the front of the room he
launches the communion like a frisbee
and he's already got the entire room to
turn around and look at him
he launches this communion like a
frisbee and it's like
everybody's heads go like this and it
skimmed
the roof it comes down and hits the
priest
perfectly in the back and rolls on the
floor
and he's just like i am the
i tell you there was a devil killers not
really impressed
well some of these italian mavic guys
that we clicked up to they were really
religious as well
and some of them moved seats away from
him
and there's one you know when the the
italian mafia are like i'll probably
just going to give them
i'm going to give them a wide berth you
know like
a bit much for them yeah that's weird
for them though you've got a member like
this is this broad english accent the
goons were loving it one of the goons i
was really tight with and he was like
yeah wow man's everything you said and
more [__] i love this guy
do you remember how it made you feel in
that time because are you so are you
feeling
like you're looking at a guy who's
shouting i am the devil
yeah and obviously you've known him for
years but how do you feel at that moment
i feel that i've got the craziest
[__] in this jail as my soul
brother
everybody here knows that and they're
not going to be looking at me to drop
the soap in the [__] shell
yeah safe yeah
yeah and people say how did you survive
this [__] you know
wild man's a good person to get arrested
with
yeah thank god for a mess ironically
yeah yeah or the devil
yeah yeah you did a talk recently was
this the first one back
since uh the passing you went to the
school did you manage that or not
okay so since well man's death
i have not done any events or
any um videos
yesterday i did a zoom talk
how was it because wild man isn't in the
content
it was okay i got through it if i would
have been talking about him
that might have triggered him was the
plan to continue with the road that you
were going down
and you know because it was talk of a tv
show and all that
are you still feeling that you want to
do that because i know he would want you
to continue with all this wouldn't he
yeah definitely so my plan is
because of the lockdown my business
model has changed
people are at home watching videos
reading books
so i've really focused on youtube it's
like completely taken over my life
it's it's it's the growth there that
i've been focusing on and just
lining up good podcast guests and
keeping the content
coming out i mean i was doing like
a live stream at night at one point on a
video in the morning and stuff
it was mental when it was like so much
content
yeah um you guys
do a video every now and then and get
massive amounts of hits
thanks to keep up with your your kind of
view level
um i'm doing over five
million a month right now which is
fantastic by the way
for those who don't know youtube numbers
yeah that's amazing
that is amazing not only that but it's
amazing mainly because
youtube's probably restricting quite a
lot of that content as well because of
what's in the videos yeah you're not a
morning guys
you're not even a monetizable guy
because of the kind of stories that are
being told so to get those views you're
doing amazingly well
well a lot of it is demonetised and
since i started to go
into the realm of exposing
child sex abuse and trafficking at the
elite level
i've just come under huge amount of
attacks on my channel and people trying
to take me down
what kind of attacks are we talking
about so
the trolling has just built up and up
and up
i was doing live streams for
a company and i had a co-host
a brilliant woman called sonia poulton
who
exposes pedophiles in parliament she's
got a documentary out she's done a lot
of work on madeleine mccann
i've seen her talk about jimmy savile
before jimmy savile really dynamic
and i really enjoyed doing those live
streams we were at the forefront of an
information revolution i believed
and it really had crazy momentum
but then numerous things
accelerated against us which
stopped our partnership and she has gone
on the record recently and said she has
researched this
and she believes that our black ops
agent provocateur
level ops against
us trying to stop all this information
from getting out
there okay so just to unpack that for
people who aren't yeah as um
you know educated as what you are on
this sort of stuff yeah what we're
suggesting here is you were pushing a
few too many buttons at a high level
because you're talking about
you know you were one of them i'd say
you were the number one guy for the
geoffrey upstairs yeah we've got the
channel
the most epstein videos over 400 videos
so you research stuff
and that is linked to the the highest
levels of government in america or
in other other places and what you're
saying is you are
probably prodding a little bit too deep
to a point where
certain people could then spend money to
send traffic your way um
bots or what whatever you know fake
trolls and all of these people who were
they
just purely make life as hard as
possible for you to do that
yeah and to completely destroy my
credibility
but i did a distasteful prank which did
arm
the opposition with fuel
to come after me and that was a mistake
okay so
explain this because obviously i'm kind
of aware of it but a lot of people might
not be
well i'm glad you are allowing me to
explain this brian and lawrence because
i've been under legal instruction not to
talk about this since it happened
by the company that i was doing the live
streams for
and that company they said what we want
you to do
is get grilled by your co-host
and admit to everything and don't try to
defend your actions
and this will blow over we're going to
suspend you for now this will blow over
but then we're going to hire you back
in november which didn't happen
so i did as they said they said you know
we're media experts
you need to listen to their us and do
this
we're going to relaunch you we're going
to do a program called atwood unleashed
and you'll be back even stronger than
ever so against my better judgment
because alarm bells were going off in my
head
i did what they said and i just admitted
to everything
and i never tried to defend myself and i
just said look
but but we've got to go over exactly
what happened
okay for you to fully understand i want
to help you through this
yeah you can explain it clearly because
obviously there's so many thoughts going
on and you've got
you've been through quite a lot there by
the sounds of it so
going back you're uncovering things and
people are trying to prod holes in your
credibility they're saying things about
you
now from what i remember there was a
woman who
was a part of the youtube channel
or she you'd you'd help rescue her from
a tough situation
yeah and she was was she living with you
or was she around you
a lot okay so the prank was a joint
effort by me and one of my podcast
guests
and my podcast guest name is callie okay
and she suffered a horrendous story of
abuse she was molested i think by an
uncle at age four
she got heavily into drugs she didn't
have the tools to deal with what
happened to her
and then she was
trafficked and classified by the home
office
as a victim of modern day slavery and
human trafficking
and i've got the home office paperwork
right right here just just the front
page is all you need to see
albert on there all right yeah
sure so he always comes well briefed
which i do like
i had well
never interviewed someone who
it was active so kelly came to me
two years before i actually did the
filming with and she told me the story
and i said look this is so dangerous
what you're telling me and what you're
going through
if we put something on camera i think
that this
is going to make things even worse for
you these traffickers might come and
kill you
so i thought about her over time and
then
this year she sent me another message
and said things are so bad
i just feel that if i don't put my story
on the internet
i am going to get killed and i really
want to do it and i said well you've had
two years to think about it if you're
that confident enough to come and do it
let's do it
so i interviewed her four times
and i set up a donation page for her
because
she was homeless and injecting cocaine
and i've lived with people who
for six years who are injecting drugs
and i know how hard it is for those
people
a lot of them people think they're just
drug addicts scum
they're out shoplifting and prostituting
what they've got nothing coming why even
help them and um
after living with the people for six
years in prison and hearing the sad
stories of abuse
this was a female equivalent to that i
thought i could make a difference in her
life
and i just want to say that we've we've
all
you know we have a laugh of the wild man
stories and all the drug stories that
you
but you have turned the corner and you
really are trying to make things better
for people who are struggling with drugs
yeah someone who was coming in from the
donation pages and i was able to get
hotels and stuff she didn't have a bank
account
but i was out helping her get the money
to to
so she wasn't homeless and then she got
she got raped and robbed
in one place and um how did that
happen was that was she sort of in the
wrong place okay one of the one of the
criticisms
that i've had for raising money for her
is that
she's a sex worker she's got a page on a
website called adult work
and she is she's advertised at over a
thousand pounds a night and she's saying
she's got horses and all of this stuff
and why would i why on earth would i
want to raise money for someone like
that
well my response to that is that is all
complete front
these sex workers and i've met a few of
them now through cali
they live sad lives of borderline
homelessness
and drug drug addicted desperation
um for people to hate on sex workers
because they're like fronting it to try
and hustle a bit of money together
it's really sickening and to see the
absolute hatred that's come in
over this so
i helped to get a place in brighton now
because she's like
street level doing things with street
people street people ended up robbing
her
the mega money that she got put together
and she said she was sexually assaulted
gil the guilford council said asked me
if i would house it for a few days
so i said yeah they were going to try
and find her a house they never did
she come to my house and i went to bed
how did you feel about that just doubted
you know because obviously
she's struggling she is a drug addict
she's obviously a sex worker
and a lot of people wouldn't have taken
her in so credit to you for that but how
are you feeling going to sleep
that night knowing that she's there are
you feeling comfortable because i've
been around dangerous situations i
didn't think anything of it
and the other thing is she is really
tough she's got a lovely personality
she's got a very sick sense of humor i
called a mini wild man and she was on
the phone a lot with wild man in in the
in the last of the mums and he he loved
her too because she had such a sick
sense of humor
they were always just ripping the piss
out of me all the time together
so i felt if it was fine so
she helped herself to a bottle of wine
while i was asleep and helped herself to
a couple of bottles of night nurse
and um comes running in the bedroom
punching herself in the head and
punching herself and
dropping on the floor and head butt in
the floor so i'm thinking holy [__] you
know i thought i was doing a good deed
this woman's crazy she's about to really
[__] hurt herself
or it might look like i've hurt her i
need to call
emergency services right now and
document this
and get her help in case she does
seriously hurt herself so i you know i
was in shock seeing this
picked up the phone in the living room
and i said look
i've got a person here right now who is
punching themselves in the head and this
person needs serious
you know medical help please can you
send someone out
she comes running in the living room and
said don't [__] call the cops on me
because she had issues of trust issues
with the authorities and stuff
i said and i said i'm not calling the
cop she goes you're calling the cops i
might as well [__] die
and then she launched herself over my
[__] balcony but
i had just enough time to [__] grab
her and stop as she was going over and
i'm on the second floor
so now i'm in double shock i've just
seen a woman punching herself in the
head and head-butting the floor
and now i've just seen a woman try and
kill herself right in front of me
so the woman the operator on the phone
says after all the podcasts and
everything is it or is this this is
after the four podcasts right
the operator so she never showed any
signs of this in those podcasts
this is quite a a new thing this is just
blown up
she's drank a bottle of wine and a
couple of bottles of nightmares and this
is just blown up now
her demons are coming out big time so
the operator says this is not a medical
matter this is now police matter we're
sending the police
so i'm like we'll just send someone asap
because she needs help so cops come
and um they talk to her they talk to me
i say look i don't press any charge
about anything because she wrecked a few
you know things were a bit
wrecked jumped on me in the bed and all
this stuff and um
can she just get mental health
assistance that's what she needs
obviously so they assured me that they
would take and she would get mental
health assistance
and the next day a police woman called
me they said she's about to be released
if i were you i would never have
anything to do with her
i know her history blah blah
ten minutes left later so the mental
health assistance was non-existent
that's what cali told me later on
ten minutes later i get a call from cali
saying um
i'm on the roadside i'm homeless i had
to make a decision then as well as hell
or not
in the meantime i'd done a video and put
it on youtube and say because people
were
engaged they donated they wanted to know
what was happening
i put a video on youtube i was all
shocked and shook up saying she's just
tried to kill herself at my apartment
and i'm not saying that yeah and if i'm
honest i thought
you've you've not played this well like
it
as a viewer you're like what the [__] we
were about to do
true news that day i think weren't we
and we were just looking over youtube
and your video was
talking about about what was going on
because in my head i felt like
all the wildness all the craziness for
you was in the past and it's
now in your books and now you're talking
about but you're a good guy you're
trying to help the kids you're trying to
get people off of drugs and now it it
felt like
you'd lost control of the situation
completely yeah completely lost control
i was in shock
and so people expressed their support
more donations came in
and then now we've got to get to the
motive behind the prank
so for perhaps over a year now
a hermaphrodite troll has been doing
videos
okay let him finish let him finish sorry
i'm afraid troll has been doing videos
about various of my podcast guests
really mean videos and these podcast
guests have been contacting me
every week or every month saying you
need to do something about this sean
this was this was the hermaphrodite that
um
wild man fell asleep when we were
interviewing her because i said i'm not
scared of my trolls i'll interview my
trolls and she came on
the podcast i thought right if it would
defuse the situation with the troll
we'll get on the podcast hear her story
and maybe she'll you know
be a nice person because the people that
she was doing the videos out were
activists about
child sex abuse a lot of them so why
what was the motivation
then all right so she so all these
people start contacting me saying you
need to do something about it
interviewing the troll did not stop the
troll the troll
actually started to attack victims
of pedophilia i'm really confused all
right first question
yeah what is hermaphrodite again um
sort of mixed and yeah mixed male and
female characteristic
so i i just because there's someone else
in the audience
so i think she's got mostly male
characteristics but she has a worm okay
yeah um so this has been ongoing
you you've got your situation with cali
so the troll started before cali sorry
but but when
when you interviewed the troll yeah this
was before cali way before california so
you interviewed a way before colleen
yeah
and how was the interview was it i mean
obviously
but it was the purpose of the interview
for her to get off her chest what she
disliked about you or was it for another
reason
what no i thought right um i wanted to
show
the world i'm not afraid of trolls and
by having this troll on
she was an ex-police person she's
probably got an interesting story
all the ex-police people i've
interviewed absolutely fascinating
stories
just like criminals have got fascinating
shows it's the other side of it isn't it
yeah so
far this person will come on tell a
story
and maybe it will cause some kind of
unity between us and the trolling will
start
though because when you're saying
trolling trolling
is you know it's often just insults
is she it just it mindlessly insulting
you or is she being critical of you
and if she was to give her side the
story and i'm just trying to play
devil's love yes
would she go well actually i was just
being critical of him because he wasn't
doing a good job or whatever
yeah or is that what she would say sort
of thing she was
making videos about victims of
pedophilia saying that they were making
it up
just to do gofundmes and these people
people had interviewed
just absolutely heartbreaking harrowing
stories so when it went from the level
of shoot just
attacking my pockets attacking victims
of pedophilia
the calls to do something about this was
starting to resound in my mind
now with cali's situation
she said
that the gulf of me was a scam
and that i was on the first floor of an
apartment not the second floor
she couldn't possibly have tried to
commit suicide of my first floor
and that the go phone because it was
going in my name on the gofundme page
cali wasn't getting any of that money i
was pocketing all of that money myself
and she was also saying that child
services
should be contacted to have callie's
child
taken away from her this was after
enough gofundme money had come in for us
to help callie get a place to live out
of and she had been reunited with her
son
all right so so now the the the attacks
in my mind are getting
really close to home and i'm thinking
right i really
need to do something about this then so
what was your what was your thought
process behind what you were gonna do
okay so we decided to
just because oh yeah she'd accused me of
setting up a trafficking operation i was
back on drugs i was snorting cocaine and
trafficking women
this was all said in the video yeah i
was i was starting cocaine and i'm
pimping kelly out
okay that's what i was doing and am i
right in saying that other people also
picked up on this information and
started making their own videos as well
so they became
yes other people basically falsely
started to accuse you of things that
weren't true
because yeah that because there were a
few a few i can't understand why they
would think that the way where would
that come from i don't i
you know like you're an author you are
doing research for
the jethro episode in case you're making
all these videos you're doing school
talks
like from all the years i've known you
from day one
i've never thought there's a man who's
money hungry and is on drugs
you've never ever acted that way you've
never
you've never been money hungry the best
and easiest
way to discredit people is to attach
some kind of sex offense to them
because even if it's disproven
it stays there there's always some kind
of yes
yeah i hate that we the minute a label
is given by anyone like that to anyone
it doesn't matter how little evidence or
how ridiculous it is
it just stays and you're [__] for life
yeah it's a shame and it also reduces
the other people who actually
do do terrible sexual things which is
kind of what we're
seeing now the people you're researching
so i'm excited i'm exposing all that
stuff
and then these four dark forces
conspire against me to try and take my
channel down but then i armed them
gave them some ammunition with the prank
which was distasteful and it was a
mistake and i do regret it and i
apologize to anybody who was offended by
it
what i want to ask though about this
prank is i'm assuming you're sat
in the living room with cali after
rescuing her again from homelessness was
that how you two
came up with it okay so the prank
um was planned and built up over a
period of months
and we thought that if we leak
stuff from my apartment
to the troll then the troll will think
they've got this scoop
and all this inside information about me
and post it but if we do like a video
showing how we leaked all this stuff to
the troll
then everybody will will you're trying
to ruin their credibility
right yeah yeah because they're trying
to ruin your credibility because what
you're trying
long story what you're trying to do is
actually take down the sex offender so
if they turn you into a sex offender
then they're trying to take you so
you're trying to make them
stupid so we had to do this in a way
that the troll would not know that we
were leaking this information
to her so photos and content was taken
in my apartment
and it looks like hidden camera sort of
stuff doesn't it someone sort of holding
a phone on their lap or
you know yeah yeah for that and some of
you were saying by me and and kelly also
had some other people
taking content now we started by leaking
some pictures
and we put them on cali's adult work
site
because we knew we'd be watching that a
girl
a woman that i'd been seeing earlier
this year
would snitch us out why is that because
she doesn't like you no more
yeah and this woman my friends call the
ass rapist
because you guys are very creative with
your names because from the day
we met she had grand designs on my bomb
that i was unaware of
what and these things involved in the
trailer these things involved plastic
arms with fists as big as yours brian
they involved a industrial strength sex
machine
sorry industrial stuff fake sperm
speculums and uh oh
no like a girl boy industrial strength
sex machine i've never heard such a
phrase
i've been either not i'm sure your
podcasts are always
wow wow but why this is this is
you know what i mean yeah yeah well i've
never i'm sorry so
can you industrially [__] someone as
opposed to just residential with it she
she wanted to use these things on you i
didn't know at the time but she'd read
party time
my book in which i'm not shy about
having
uh i think me and my wife in la at dj
kyoki's house had mini
vibrating eggs in our bums and i'm not
shy about the
anal g-spot in it so she'd read party
time
and set her sights on me because this
was her specialty
when you say it was a specialty so
you're saying she'd done something
you don't help yourself sometimes yeah
i'm just gonna put that out there
i didn't know what she had in mind well
i'm waiting for your book do you know
that
jesus i'm just not sure that you're sort
of reading the science
no yeah yeah there's times when you when
you meet a woman
who is on the kinky side as we all know
i have
um the signs are there do you know
we you know you were just completely all
right so she sent me an email
and she said i've read your book party
time here's some pictures of me
oh there we go she was a beautiful
blonde czech woman
39 years old into her sports and fitness
and a lot of other things plenty of
fists am i right
she said she wanted me i said yeah
that's me dating website plenty of
things so
so so i need to help we hooked up
briefly and i say briefly it was over a
month or so
i was seeing about once a week and it
had to
end because of her i realized what she
was and
the damage that was occurring to my bum
okay there was two times i left her with
my bum bleeding
wow so wait okay yeah
all right so um
i mean this in the most sensitive way we
need to unpack this yeah yeah
yeah because you know that night
you're obviously you're headed around or
she's headed around to yours with the
ice in a bag
sex dolls and everything's in the sex
toys sex dolls
right okay so you're still getting your
kickstand sean fair play yeah
play to you and as you should me at no
age should uh
sexual exploration stop it between two
consenting adults
she was consenting and you were as well
as naughty as this is
wrong with laying it down what was going
to happen so the first time i go to see
it we have normal sex it's brilliant
she gets a finger in i'm fine with that
but then she starts saying little things
like
we're gonna have to make this bigger
unless you start she starts showing me a
dildo and collection
and stuff
how many dildos are we talking oh a
house
right full spent more on this stuff than
her rent right she's literally
so it's about to quickly learn so it's a
bit of an obsession for her yeah
it comes across that way yeah and
towards the end of it she said to me
that um she confessed that she was on
the adult i've been on the adult work
site
and she specialized in torturing men's
bums
i thought this was a gymshark sponsor
she said she sits around all day
thinking up ways
to torture men's bombs wow and
her specialty was people pay 500 to a
grand they'd fly in
she'd go to the hotel room [__] slap
them
throw them around throw them in the
shower make them do an anal douche and
then terrorize the [__]
and then tell should tell them to [__]
off back home
but she would she said one of her add-on
services was cookies
and she'd mail them [__] cookies and
then they would pay hundreds of pounds
for those so shucky
you but this is the thing she's getting
paid to do this [__] this is her sort of
business
yeah why does she want to carry on doing
it in her personal life
okay so i did not know she got a kick
she's she's dropping these hints like
bigger things need to go in there i've
got this sex machine let me get the sex
machine now
these red flags i need the description
of this machine did she get the machine
out
yeah right describe it because i'm i've
never
as as experienced as i am laurence
you've never used a
i thought i was a man of the world yeah
and i'd experienced everything
i've experienced nothing yes i'm
imagining like a fridge
with a with a dildo on the face every
time i left her house i called hammy
right away wildman's cousin
he's like what's she done what's
happening what's happened no he'd never
heard these things as well
and it was him who came up with the name
for her the rate the ass rapist
creative guy quite an i yeah so the sex
machine
about as big as this chest there's a
chest spot roving just frame that up for
us
thanks there's this chest over here yeah
jesus
and it had various
so i'm just going to say if you're
listening on itunes or spotify
the chest is about a meter long and it's
built if it's massive yeah if there's
any you remember old films where they
sort of caught big chests onto a train
when the
rich family are going on so it's about
that size and then if you didn't make a
lot of noise or
oh let me tell ya so it had various
tubes on the top of it right here
mounting a dildo i'm guessing yes right
for melting various
dildo attachments right so she had a
whole set of attachments
that just fit upon the sex machine right
the sex machine then plugged into a wall
and if you've ever been at a raid is it
if you've
you've wanted to get right up to the
speaker that's vibrating the post
the whole room the whole room
was vibrating must have such a life yeah
i mean to be fair you could think of a
washing machine i'm sure they're
screaming probably
but uh some people just love the washing
i can't wait to see a photograph of this
woman by the way you must have one i
know
i'm not allowed to show any photographs
i'm not being funny [__] the audience i
need to see what you look private
this is mental perfectly yeah okay so
so being the uh open-minded
explorational guy that you are you you
give it a whirl
so she says to make your ass bigger
because the sex machine is vibrating
at such a frequency if you sit on these
various things
right it'll kind of slowly enlarge it
so it didn't work for me i only you know
i'm down with the anal g spot with a
finger in there or something but i don't
want my ass [__]
made into made into a cavern yeah
where the people started what a podcast
i don't be driving home with [__]
falling out
um so all right so make cookies out of
it
so she goes all right we'll we'll try
the speculum
i'll do it on my [__] first right i've
seen these in porn before so this is a
metal thing that sort of you jump in and
then you open it up yeah
oh like that's like a medical thing yeah
yeah exactly yeah yeah or
i mean it's whatever you want it to be
sorry oh she goes i'll do it on my [__]
first
jesus so she gets on the bed and does
the speculum thing now this is not
they're sort of made for vaginas they
want me so this has gone beyond like
sex for me now this is just like
curiosity now i'm not getting
turned on i'm just thinking what is she
going to come up with next this is just
i'm just curious how fast this one will
go
this is the next book really the captain
so she's on the bed with the speculum
i've never seen anything like it this
looks like cavernous pink walls and you
could just see all the way in and
she made you look you were just sort of
yeah she's checking it out she's like
warming me up to do it on my bum
how uh how big was this thing roughly
how long well that's it you cranked the
speculum open don't you say it widens
how long is it it's quite sort of like
six
okay like how long in here was it yeah
how far
it's a circle uh-huh that's just cranked
her open
right now you can just see all that deep
you can see a depth
yeah because it's like it just opens
everything up why does it wow
this girl is wild yeah me honestly yeah
yeah and so she once she was basically
um
pitching that you did this so then she
did do it
so she did the speculum on me and i
had to tell her to stop quite quickly
and she goes oh don't worry i'm gonna
if it's hard i'm gonna rim your bum
don't worry probably should've done that
before
yeah yeah kiss it better firstly
so she's [__] and the pain is intense
from the speculum it feels like
one of my elastic bands is going to
stand like take it up take it off two
minutes so that didn't work very well
either
yeah and and so we've really got off
so where were you when this were you in
in in the country with uh
in her country no no this is in the uk
okay we don't seem to say we're about to
no because she's had a stalk and i don't
want to get her any trouble okay okay so
yeah
she's those kind of people attract those
stuff so this is happening
and how does that little relationship
unfold how do you get on with her from
there we'll get back to the whole
[__]
other thing so there's all kinds of wild
crazy sex stuff that we did
all right give me give me some ideas
it's at the point where she's
uh we're choosing an ai sex doll
together
and um male or female female
just children she wants to have three
sums of an ai sex though that was the
thing right how good are they these days
i've
i've seen that we didn't end up having a
threesome
it's not a threesome
again it's not a real person so it's not
a threesome is it it's just well what
kind of pricing are we looking at what
kind of
oh yeah these are like thousands of
pounds and are you specking it up sort
of thing like you know can you get the
m1 chip in it or like what are you
yeah there's all kinds of different okay
and they reply they talk to you they
and then it just sort of sits there
apart from that and do you pick the hair
color
because we've seen the documentary we've
seen we think we've watched this on true
news before like the kind of
these people make them and they you know
use breasts eyes and
all these kind of things she'd picked
one out with big boobs and everything
right yeah so so you're i'm assuming
you're not that into this you're just
sort of going along with it for the fun
the normal sex was amazing but then she
wanted to
demolish my bum at a higher level every
week she was like
it was going up and we had a
conversation at the end when she said
that's
that's what she was doing she was trying
to break me in because these things that
she fantasizes about doing even though
it's a career
she's made a career out of it because
she naturally just thinks about that
stuff all day long she's like honey too
it's a bit like you and football
lawrence it's identical right yeah you
think about football turn it into a job
yeah exactly yeah i was just so obsessed
with just making football bigger
make football great yeah let's see so
i'm on the phone to have me giving you
my weekly reports as to what's happened
what's gone down
the fake sperm that all these different
contraptions so she was
sort of obsessed in fake sperm as well
because obviously there's a bit of a she
was you
i okay so that's coming out of a toy i'm
assuming
yeah she wanted to jizz yeah in people's
bums with fake sperm
right which is understandable i think a
lot of women are probably at some point
gum
what's that like do you know what i mean
i don't even know there was such a thing
as fake spells you must be curious
though
it's just icing sugar probably you must
be curious it sounds like a real swell
mother
yeah just for all the people out there
coming as a man is amazing
so yeah i mean i i admire a woman
who is um up for doing random things
like this
but at the same time she's taking it a
bit too far
man i told i called hammy the last two
times i left the house
i told him about the blood in my [__]
and he's like you gotta
stop you can't you can't keep going like
this you're gonna have [__] seriously
internal
serious internal damage yeah especially
during coronavirus it's very difficult
to go to you know
yeah do you and she was acting a bit
crazy and she kept looking at me this
stir and she said if you know if we stop
seeing each other
i'll never ever harm you and in my head
i knew
this woman is gonna [__] try and
destroy me
if we ever stop seeing each other
sean welcome to being a celebrity
because when people don't want to
[__] let you go and you try and let
go
and they don't want to let you go yeah
i'll do anything it takes to take you
down now
yeah believe me so i'm thinking i can
recycle that
by leaking her the photo because
we've been watching and laughing at
together the hermaphrodite videos
so she knew all about the hermaphrodite
and knew that hermaphrodite was trying
to get me with anything possible
so by putting the picture of cali on
adult work
and this woman the ass rapist being on
poured a picture of kelly on my balcony
we knew what would happen next right
with her by this point um yeah
how was that breakup how did that
conversation go
you're getting too attached and
i tried to just be as gentle as possible
ironic
uh there's blood on my [__] but i'm
gonna be as gentle as possible yeah
exactly
yeah i mean you can't bring up all the
sex stuff sometimes it's probably bad to
bring up sex stuff during the breakup
you kind of want to make it about that
yeah you don't want to go down that
route really because actually if
anything that's helping her get off on
it
this this mental blackmail that was put
on you there's not enough understood
about this or
acknowledged in uh modern day society
because obviously
when when men hurt women um
often it is physical and it leaves
physical marks and you're
much more able to go to the police about
that but when you're being blackmailed
or you're being threatened mentally
no one can deal with that really
especially with women it's often sort of
oh yeah
if you go with the police with that they
don't do anything they're not going to
do anything
it's hard to quantify isn't it yeah
you've got to take matters into your own
hands unfortunately
i don't know if you played it right but
what led to what late
why why do this specific plan that you
came up with because
obviously looking back now hindsight's
2020 is a it's a bad plan
yeah okay i am completely desensitized
and cali
is completely desensitized and we
thought if we just go balls to the wall
and do the sickest joke possible
and the only way we're going to fool the
troll is if we send the content that is
really sick
that she would think they can't possibly
be leaking this to me because this is
just so sick
right then once we show the making of
the prank
everyone will be on our side and the
night we showed the prank
we were slapping each other on the back
saying what good actors we were
like we've really done a solid okay so
there's people from all over the world
who saw it were contacting me saying
thank god you took that troll down and
her
channel got slaughtered right and for
days we thought we thought we'd
pulled it off okay so just to describe
the video that you actually
there was a couple that i see yeah one
is where carly looks like she's about to
perform
a sexual act on you although you don't
actually say any nudity or anything like
that yeah
um your your breathing and that made me
feel slightly uncomfortable
it looks like you're using drugs um
snorting flower
and you're talking to her about oh money
and stuff like that and give us the cash
and
it you know to me who knows you uh i was
like this doesn't i stack up your this
isn't who he is like you know but
obviously
if you're desperate for you to be this
bad guy you're going to take it
hoop like so you thought you'd won yeah
you then had a whole making of
the prank video that you then released
to show that it was all a joke
yeah why do you what what went wrong
after that did something go wrong it
felt it feels like it didn't
end up the way you planned it okay so
you ended up taking that video
down that showed the prank being made
yeah yeah i had to take everything down
so what happened was
i armed the trolls and the trolls
started to make all these videos using
like little clips of it and stuff and
getting people outraged
and they contacted the company i was
doing the live streams for
and then the the company that i was
doing the live streams for then they
took matters into the
with their own hand and said you know
you do these um
apology videos and get grilled by the
co-host
and then don't ever speak about this
what did you apologize for
exactly though because to me although
what are you apologizing for
okay so the main thing that caused the
problem was
the video of her on her knees in the
right in the mid and i've learned what
the outfit was recently because someone
sent me a link to it on amazon
it's a milk-made outfit with cat ears
okay and because she used the word daddy
in it and because me and my co-host
were at the forefront of activism
exposing
pedophiles and child sex abuse and
trafficking
to some people it was distasteful that
i did that in a prank did you um
had you sort of uh you just not mentally
made that connection
because i'm desensitized i come from a
place you know that was prison gang
rapes and beheading stories and seeing
blood square out of people's heads and
all that kind of
thinker through in that regard i was
thinking i was going to get credited
with
destroying this troll now for people
who've criticized
um some people have said right that
cali is artistic and i basically i've
just got someone soft in the head on her
knees
and took advantage of her now cali is
high
functioning aspergic she is like
has a photographic memory and she has
his genius level of things she sent me
some of her writing
she can't spell for [__] but she writes
prose like an artist and i the first
time she showed me some of her writing
you're an author yourself so you're
qualified to judge this yeah first time
you showed me some writing i said who
wrote that
so if you wrote that don't [__]
insult me i wrote that
it was that beautiful her prose okay
so if she was let's just say
if she was um soft in the head and i
took advantage of her
and and did all this let's just assume
that the criticisms were correct
the people who would call me out the
most on that would be her family members
so let me read a text sent to me
by her foster mother
who was aware of the prank and
everything unaware of the backlash
and she said um about the backlash it
sounds harsh and hectic
brother surely everyone can have a sense
of humor
if a trafficked woman can make a joke
about being trafficked
the viewers should find some compassion
instead of judgment
but it was distasteful to some people
and i do regret it and i wish i hadn't
done it was like it was like my suicide
forest moment on my channel yeah
it was um i'm your mate and i want to be
really truthful with you i think you
built up a
large level of uh credibility in your
books in your speaking
helping children helping with everything
you're trying to take down
and you [__] up yeah because you gave
them
that ability to try and take you down
and and take away from the good stuff
yeah and take things out of context you
know
um yeah you've made some i can't judge
because i've made crazy life decisions
when i've got
popular and done stupid things that i
regret and stuff and
you know you you haven't actually hurt
anyone though you know what i mean you
haven't actually tried to hurt anyone
you haven't hurt anyone you've just made
a stupid mistake
and you didn't think it through clearly
the motivation was pure it was to take
someone down who was trying to have
cali's kid taking the work
away from us asking people to snitch and
call social services
the biggest mistake you can ever make
with a troll is actually acknowledging
that they actually
first i know and that's the desperation
the
the campaign's against me this is how
sneaky they are
so these channels that are putting
videos up
on one of the channels they interviewed
someone and these people are purporting
to be my former subscribers and patreon
donors
and this woman who was recently
interviewed who got thousands of views
she said i used the tragic thing is i
used to love sean atwood i've supported
him for years
in fact i was his patreon donor three
years ago
and she goes on and on just says all
these lies for about an hour and gets
thousands of views on it
my patreon's only been up for just over
a year
so but they are sucking in some of my
subscribers to believe these things and
so to try and help those subscribers
not believe those things i've addressed
some of the trolls concerns so the
trolls said that the balcony was on the
first
i was on the first floor wasn't the
second floor she couldn't possibly
wanted to commit suicide
so we did a video of me dropping a melon
off the second floor
and then the troll said i'd obviously
gone in my neighbor's apartment and
dropped them
then they said the gofundme i'd i'd
spent all that money on myself
they they complained to gofundme and
said
i was committing fraud so gofundme
launched this investigation
and these weren't the donors people were
still donating money after the prank
these are busy bodies trolls and
troublemakers but the more you respond
to them i know the worse it gets because
the
the more that they feel like there is a
fight yes the more the fight intensifies
from there
yes yes yes are you going i'm going to
drop a watermelon off here to prove that
you guys are wrong
that the more that antagonizes them i've
completely stopped now because i did
that
to show the people who were my followers
don't be getting tricked by these people
the gofundme thing was the last i got
all the bank statements proved it all
went to cali's rent
sent all that to my co-host uh on the
live streams that was all
authorized um go from me cleared it all
and um that's the last i've ever done to
respond to the trolls i'm not going to
be responding to the trolls ever again
but yeah you can't
you could not only can you not respond
yeah you can't even listen
yeah because yeah there's difference
between true criticism
of a real fan who really likes you and
says look i think you made a mistake
with this or whatever
yeah but this is just to try and
mentally [__] you and the more that you
actually read
i remember like a while ago i was
reading a comment that was just like
like a troll comment just to hurt your
feelings i thought
ah i'm not doing this anymore me like
i'm out of this i'm finished
yeah over yeah and if that means i'm
going to miss some of the nice ones as
well
but i focus on making the videos and
that actually
gives the fans what they really want yes
then then i'm doing what i need to do
and then mentally
at least i'm not getting [__] off
about it or bothered about it
so i i was i was i had a good attitude
towards the trolls for a year but i just
snapped over this situation and what
you're saying is 100
true channel that energy into content
creation for your genuine fans and
that's gonna rule the day
so how does that play into the darker
side of things where there are actual
you you saying they're actual people who
are trying to silence you
yeah do you think these two separate
issues
or these two things somehow intelligent
in your mind
i believe that it is all interlinked
and that there are various trolling
missions going on right now with people
with different motivations
um people i've pissed off for one reason
or another people
in power who just want my reputation
destroyed
and just you know just teenagers just
getting off on it adding adding to the
action so
yeah so there's the regular trolls which
we all have but you think that there's a
little bit of a higher level of thing
going on because of the
the content that you're making is
generally about high-level government
conspiracies in regards to child
sex and stuff like that so sonia my
co-host said she has researched it and
she believes that there is
proper high-level black ops aging
provocateur stuff
going on to destroy the information
that we were getting out so which cases
in particular
that you've covered do you think would
have provoked that sort of stuff well
look at the names that we've
concentrated on prince andrew
and wild man kept joking you're going to
go for a jog one day in the forest and
prince andrew's guys are going to come
and get you
can we can we cover a little bit of this
situation right now yeah so since we
last spoke to you
um really very little has happened to
the sky they've gone very very quiet
they've protected him
they've took them back into the royal
circle and that's the end of that really
it's it's you know he what he admitted
to realistically
the that car crash interview that he did
anyone else
that was quite good actually
entertaining yeah
but when you look at someone who
basically doesn't have the answers
and and god knows how they let that
happen i mean it just shows how
carefree the royal family can be
sometimes with how untouchable they
actually are
and people really underestimate what the
royal family actually are in this in
this country
but you obviously you know um what is
the situation with that case right now
where are we
okay so galain maxwell who prince andrew
knew from when she was in university
she was raided and she is pending trial
right now in america
so the memes are like when she gonna get
suicided or coveted
because if she starts naming people it
would be at the level of prince andrew
and bill clinton
and when i'm asked about that my
response is that
she will it will never go to trial
because when names are
come out in court certain government
agencies have to take action upon them
those names will have to be protected so
in the interest of national security
she'll be told sign a plea bargain go to
prison
do so many years get on with your life
and by national security what we mean is
if the if the rest of the american
people found out the true details of
what bill clinton was up to
as president and postdoc there'd be hell
on
so we have to make sure that that
doesn't come out exactly and a lot of
people are waking up now to the cocaine
trafficking that the bush and clinton
crime families did to finance that war
in nicaragua
but the sex stuff trafficking of kids
and exploiting teenagers and
for people to comprehend that if you are
that powerful that you're a president or
a prince you engage in that activity for
some people that's too much of a
contradiction for them to accept it in
their heads
so where else is is your research taking
you at the moment i mean epstein
obviously
um that that case is now still going
really isn't it
so the epstein case we're still
reporting on that regularly i've
partnered up with ron swanson shout out
to him
he's got a youtube channel and he does
research on the dark web
and that's really horrific stuff
such as red rooms what's a red room
so a red room is where by they're live
streaming the torture of a kid
and the possible murder of a kid and you
get to pay
for the various levels of torture and
you can even pay to have the kid killed
and what who was doing this and who was
watching this
so wealthy predator pedophile
people all over the world watch these
things
the kids are sourced in countries like
the philippines
and there are cases where you know these
people have been busted and it's
it's gone to the court system i was
watching a documentary the other day
you might have seen it on netflix called
i think it's called tell me who i am
oh yeah about the twitter brothers so um
and it's about the it's like our
aristocratic society
basically where one brother at 18 19
years old
gets into an accident car accident can't
remember anything other than his own
brother his own
his own twin brother basically recreates
their life and tells them
a completely different life story and as
they get older
the mother dies they climb into the
attic or whatever and they find these
pictures of him
naked as boys and then his brother has
to basically admit like
we were basically used by
the mother and father and sent out to
other rich families
while we were young boys and handed
around the men
and you know in this sort of level of
wealth it was sort of not an unusual
thing and
i guess it's just sort of mind-blowing
um that how
quiet this is but how possibly
widespread it could be
and i've interviewed some experts on it
and i've said if people got all this
money
and power why on earth do they want to
do this stuff with kids
you know could get them in serious
trouble but
maybe pedophilia is a lot more common
than what we actually
realize but at that level
because money affords you opportunity
to have whatever you want they're able
to
get away with it in in by paying for it
etc you know i mean let's be honest
michael jackson is the [__]
king of pop no he's the king of
pedophiles actually um
was paying parents and and and paying
off children
20 million the first kid got by the way
for [__] decades
and yet because we all like his music
and because a lot of people like his
music they refuse to [__] acknowledge
the dozens of children that came forward
like
uh how come this is just a little mini
rant of mine but how come we all believe
the women who came out about or kelly
and rightly so but all of the children
the job oh they just want the money you
know it's like actually i think you find
children are quite believable
they're very believable you know and
it's that mental contradiction that
people can't cope with
um in my research there was someone
present at a dinner that george h.w bush
was hosting and someone asked bush
you know how can you be waging this war
on drugs
while at the same time running all these
drugs in through the cia to finance this
war in nicaragua
and he said that it's so far removed
from what the public
would possibly believe that's how i get
away with it and that is the case
in many of these sort of high-level
criminals isn't it whatever they're in
new whatever they're doing if they're
in the face and they're smiling there's
a thing called elite deviants
and that states that if you have got all
this power and money
a you've got the resources to get away
with it if you get caught
and b to get your thrills and kicks
you've got to do stuff that's sicker and
sicker and sicker and that's what leads
to pedophilia
and and i'm not suggesting that trump
and biden
are pedophiles but if you look into them
there's so many things that are
questionable
in regards to the way they attract women
and i mean if you there's
compilations of joe biden
inappropriately touching children
compilations the president the man who
was president
has got that many cases against him that
he's paid that many people off trump and
these are the two guys running
and they're both questionable
backgrounds sexually in regards to
people like this is the presidential
election
and the both guys not just one and
they're in this
seven like it blows my mind how this is
the world i'm living
in like it's [__] insane it's all
public persona versus satanic persona
the media does a good job with the spin
but it's the internet thanks to the rise
of the internet that's enabling us to
expose a lot of this stuff mind you
though
like we we uncovered like um
there was a tweet that when sort of like
we were doing um a bit of research of
the day about covid or something and we
we seen like there was a tweet that was
tweeted out
like thousands of times by so many
different accounts about how we need to
enforce people to have
the vaccine and stuff like make sure
that and we're looking like where are
all this
where's this come from and it's like so
what what it seems like
is although the internet has been our
freedom of information to get it
they they're getting their fingernails
on it now and they're starting to find
ways to use it in their
direction that one day yeah i mean look
at what they're doing to julian assange
if anyone needs some help it's him he
sacrificed
his life for the truth he's the only
person in journalism who everything he's
ever published has been shown to be
hundred percent true
what are they doing to julian assange
now just because it's kind of hard to
find out
when um well he's in prison around here
and he's getting they're trying to
extradite him to america where they were
calling for the death penalty on him at
one point for treason and
how does treason work because um
if what you say is found to be true
obviously in a way you've sort of just
done the right thing in that sense
that's why it's kind of
it's for again for a lot of people it's
a contradiction he's done he's revealed
something that ultimately seemed to help
the public
which is what the government is supposed
to do so there's quite a there's a very
there's difficult mental gymnastics you
have to do to find him to be the bad guy
the prosecutors have framed it that he
was in a conspiracy with chelsea manning
to expose things that endangered
people who were in operations around the
world they've never ever come forward
and shown anyone who was
endangered by the information that
julian assange put out
but that's the spin that they put on it
how do you how do you feel holding um
so much of this kind of information and
how do you um
you know for example when we see david
ike you've interviewed david like
right a few times obviously i don't
agree with everything he says but you
can clearly tell he's done a lot of
research and
sometimes he just looks like the weight
of the world's on his shoulders because
he is just sort of
and it does feel like you're you're kind
of following in those footsteps a little
bit and i never
when we first interviewed you it was
about your story
and yes you were doing research but the
more you go on the more you're sort of
heading in that direction too and when
you look at how
it served david ike much of which has
been
hatred and backlash and ridicule
it's a it's not a really rewarding path
to walk are you sure you want to do this
mit
i think my channel started out as
interviewing people who'd been in prison
and then it branched out into various
true crime stories but then it started
to really focus on victims of abuse
and it's great to have people on who've
been victims of abuse to get their
stories out and to see all the feedback
and the love they get and how that
really helps them and shapes
what they're doing in their lives it's
really powerful
but when i'm talking to these people
and absorbing the darkness even though i
am desensitized on the surface i do
imagine
that it's accruing inside me and perhaps
has contributed
to me making the mistake with the prank
because
as you destabilize emotionally your
rational thought processes reduce
and then you're more prone to making
mistakes and i think i destabilized
emotionally
but specifically in regards to the
conspiracy level that you're going to in
the
epstein stuff and you've covered that
more than anyone on the internet as we
said
you're you know like like wild man was
making those jokes but you're putting
yourself at risk you're you're giving
yourself a lot to live with you don't
know who the [__] is around the corner
who's watching you
is that you just sort of ignoring that
and thinking
not thinking about it or does it make
you feel anywhere
something happened to me when i was a
teenager and i just think that
i suppressed it and people who've been
through things
i relate to them and i feel that the
mission
to get those stories out there is more
important than the risks of my personal
safety
fair enough so as for wild man
um it's it's very recently he's passed
away what was the situation with his
um burial and stuff or his cremation so
the information i got was that the
oxygen mask had come off him
and there was an investigation and now
they've told me that it was multiple
organ failure but because of corona
and the backlogging
funerals and autopsies and things like
that
that perhaps that the funeral will be at
the latter half of
december and researching
about funerals during this epidemic i
think only 30 people can attend funerals
god it's it's ridiculous i'm sorry
uh that that you're gonna go through
that like not having
able to have everyone there when we've
got anthony joshua fighting this month
with a thousand people allowed to attend
and yet people you got 30 people maxed
at a funeral it's [__] mental this
thing
and this is the inconsistencies that's
really [__] me off with the [__]
no see you've got people saying goodbye
to their loved ones via facetime
and then you've got anthony joshua a
little box with a thousand people there
no disrespect because i love aj
but it's just like where's the
consistency here this is insane
yeah in a funeral do you actually see
the person
well you can go to see them at the
chapel of rest beforehand in my
experience
um if it's a burial especially that's
what happened
in my experiences previously and if you
get the chance
i'd recommend it to have that moment
with them
i do want to do that yeah i think
that'll be lovely it'll be hard
but and you know but they're they're
just asleep mate yeah
and it's you're seeing your friend
asleep some sometimes the place you
least want to look is the place you
look you know and i think that's
probably really important in that moment
yeah have that if you can
i hope that you get that because um
you know it's never goodbye because you
know what the great thing about dying is
we all do it and it's not an exclusive
club and although it feels like goodbye
right now
it isn't goodbye because whatever i
don't know about
religion and all of that [__] but i do
know wherever wild man goes
you're going the same placement because
you didn't have the same [__]
i'll yeah
genuinely wherever he's that's it isn't
it and his family and hammy
really appreciated that so much love
came out for him
that it was trending on twitter for six
hours and i've got to credit you guys
with doing your tweets to get that
in motion every minute every few minutes
it was r.i.p wild man for six hours i
had no
idea amazing the amount of love and
support and the kindness of people from
all over the world
so yeah thanks very much for doing that
thank you from his family as well
well this podcast was dedicated to
peter mahoney aka the wild man
yes and there's um over 100 videos on
his
playlist on my channel yeah but worth a
look
yeah we'll put the link for that in the
description on the donation link
for his daughter in there as well make
sure that um any money you guys want to
donate will go to his daughter
um check out sean atwood's youtube
channel
i'm sure it's going to be eventful after
everything you told us today almost at
600k subs
you started it you've worked your ass
off
thank you i'm proud of you now um focus
on what you do best which is getting
that content open
definitely yeah some lessons learned
this year for many people
yeah i'm sure yeah i think this virus
has been like a stress test on society
whereby it says test on relationships
business
relationships people's health and it's
affecting people all over the world
and it's watching videos like yours you
know your workout video and stuff
i think it's just so important right now
during this time
that we keep creating that content
because people are stuck at home
and things that we just think are
run-of-the-mill and normal
you get an email scenes from someone i
was feeling suicidal i watched you guys
clowning about something and it made me
think twice about what i was going to do
to myself
yeah i think we've always known podcasts
give people
uh they're like the other member at the
table who wasn't
joining in but he's with us and the
amount of uh
messages we get about you know where
they did the spotify thing recently
where it comes out oh
how many numbers people listen to and
just just nice little messages saying
you helped me get through the year
and uh it's been a [__] hard year for
everyone i think we can all agree on
that so hopefully uh
we'll get you back on next year and
it'll be a bit better thank you very
much and
huge thank you to all the viewers and
subscribers for all the love and support
really appreciate it through what's
happened
all right don't forget to hit that like
button stay subscribed the true jordan
youtube channel
r.i.p why am i thank you well done
oh well done i really needed that on the
scene
i just needed that with [__] with
people i really trust